welcome back to New Ro Stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown compilation
of every episode of M Marvel on Disney
plus along with my exclusive postseason
interview with Kamala Khan herself Iman
valani with the Marvel's coming to
theaters we wanted to put all of our
analyses of the M Marvel series from
Summer 20122 into one massive
compilation video for anyone who didn't
see the series or anyone who wants a
recap so what you're about to see is my
Episode by episode Easter egg breakdowns
that are already Elsewhere on the
channel we just wanted to compile them
this way for those who have been asking
for a longer recap podcast Style video
on who Kamala is what she's gone through
and why the MCU was so intent on linking
her with mutant kind I'm actually going
to leave in my week toe speculation just
so you can relive how fun it was to
experience that series even when the
theories were debunked the following
week you're getting sweaty summer 2022
Eric Voss wartz and all but I think all
of these breakdowns are fascinating to
rewatch especially my interview with
Iman which we are including at the end
of this video because a lot of what she
said comes under new light now that the
marbles is here specifically what she
says about Kang and what she says about
the MCU mutant plan if you want to
support us new rockstars has a Marvel
themed flurin shirt available at nerd
rot. shop and without further Ado let's
rewind the clock 18 months and enjoy
these breakdowns of Miss Marvel this is
a breakdown of Miss Marvel episode 1
which makes us wonder why are the only
superpowers I Le fan conventions with
sunburn and Co let's break down this
first episode shot by shot for the many
MCU Easter eggs and details that you
might have missed and I was fortunate
this time to talk to the directors of
this episode ad Dylan balal who gave me
some exclusive insights that I will be
including in this breakdown the Marvel
Studios title card has now been updated
with a shot of Doctor Strange from
Multiverse Madness and then on the M
it's our man moonight over this we hear
the weekend's blinding lights a tease
for the Aesthetics of this series many
shots have blinding lens flares of the
same kind of purple fuchsia color of
Miss Marvel's hard light and the weird
realm that she goes to and it is
literally blinding light that activates
kamala's Powers at the convention all of
this reflecting how Camala
metaphorically finds herself Blinded By
the Light of her own new cosmic Powers
both how cool they are and the burden of
being a superhero this opening sequence
is I love it a YouTube video as Kamala
uses her drawings to recap the events of
Avengers ingame now Kamala KH first
appeared as a fan of Captain Marvel
Carol Danvers in a 2013 Captain Marvel
comic and then shortly after got her own
spin-off in 2014 from writer G Willa
Wilson that explored her point of view
as a Pakistani American Muslim teenager
in Jersey City and really a total Marvel
Stan that whole one step removed fandom
is at the heart of this character and
why so many Comics readers as Marvel
fans ourselves could connect with her
and it's just so great that this series
opens with a Marvel fan video I Feel
seen Iman valani herself is an MCU nerd
who carries around with her a notebook
filled with MCU notes and questions who
I found out in the press conference is a
big fan of this channel might be
watching right now I hope so all this to
say this opening feels super authentic
we start with kamala's drawings
including grouchy Hulk and then hands
together with bismal an expression
meaning in the name of God an expression
that characters say throughout this
episode we see her flying sloth and then
Bigfoot with his nether regions and
upper regions covered by stars Kamala
says this is a 10-part series on Earth's
Mightiest Hero using the Avengers
moniker but describing Captain Marvel's
savior role in endgame we see drawings
of cap Iron Man Hulk black panther thick
Thor and a CO slaying thanos's forces in
the final charge of endgame Hawkeye is
using a rubber band bow flinging some
tax there's a Post-It note listing
Captain Marvel's sightings sandy beaches
Tokyo dark alley and an arena Mara says
the Avengers were losing at this point
in the battle and she's not wrong it was
really an all's lost moment when Captain
Marvel showed up I like how we see the
main Avengers joined by Wanda maximoff
Ant-Man Valkyrie and pepper pot's rescue
and we see Cap's Shield broken Kamala
says Thanos was being a jerk about
magical stones of course referring to
the Infinity Stones we see his warship
with boo you suck on a note in the
corner we hear an eagle Screech over a
bird with a Carol danver's Mohawk right
below that is a drawing of Proxima
midnight and then we see Carol's fighter
jet and Carol flying past a sign that
reads the future is female then some
Comics art of Captain Marvel flying
through space and Camala drags an MS
paint file of Captain Marvel across her
desktop screen what generation of
computer is she using and I love it
Camala mentioned studying Scott Lang's
podcast it's called Big me little me on
this powered life which must be a parody
of This American Life that does
interviews with superheroes in the MCU
suggesting that this superhero
confessional podcast was how the public
of the MCU you learned of everything The
Avengers did during the infinity war and
endgame events and this might have been
what informed Paul greengrass's film the
snap that we saw on the inflame movie
screen in Spider-Man far from home just
a cool little detail that actually tells
us a lot about the MCU now when I asked
the directors of Dylan balala about
other Avengers having podcasts in the
MCU here's what they had to say do you
think any other Avengers might have a
podcast series other than Scott Lang why
it would be it would be great to I mean
I would love to know what the Hulk you
know what his podcast is you know that
or de I mean Deadpool would be funny I
think imagine you have Deadpool and
Blades doing a doing a podcast that
would be pretty cool you heard it here
folks MCU Canon played in Deadpool have
a podcast together I think we should
call it steak Chim chunga steak spelled
s a k Kamala Recaps how in in-game Carol
flew directly through thanos's Fleet
also how she changed her hair for this
return and she did take on Thanos one by
one Camala does leave out though how
Carol Denver got wall up pretty hard
with the Power Stone I like how cap and
Scott l are seene with actual Band-Aids
on them and you can see how their torn
limbs are taped back together with
Scotch tape Cala addresses how Carol the
cosmic Avenger is not on Earth currently
recalling roie calling Carol out an
endgame and setting up whatever the plot
will be for when Kamala con joins Monica
Rambo and Carol Danvers in the film the
Marvels here we see photos of kamala's
friends Bruno and Nakia and her brother
Amir and in this animation when Carol
returns that the Avenger con beside a
cap Shield is a War Machine Head winking
over at a Carol head smooch which is a
nod to the romance between these two
characters in the comics and maybe in
the MCU I mean they had that moment
where they looked at each other in
endgame Kamala says she has a two part
series on why Thor is secretly a gamer a
reference of course to Thor playing
fortnite in endgame and she says new
episodes drop every Wednesday a nod to
how this series drops on Wednesdays her
YouTube channel is sloth baby
Productions two subscribers oh you'll
get there must be Bruno and Akia since
they both leave comments on this video
now the M Marvel press conference
included me asking Iman valani directly
if Kamala Khan subscribed to new rock
stars and she said that she wasn't sure
but probably at least a variant of us so
sweet of her to be so kind to us we love
you Aman especially since you know the
artist of the show here we're citing new
rock stars with these thumbnails and
video titles truth revealed on the real
Carol Danver story Ant-Man of the Wasps
romantic vacation in Paris I like how
that flying ant has a beret and then
where did she get her powers bitten by a
radioactive feminist on this day camalo
wears a shirt reading ladies let's get
information with have Captain Marvel
Valkyrie and wasp parodying the Beyonce
song and we meet her family her brother
Amir her father Yousef and her mother
MBA of the three I like how Yousef is
the rule breaker he tells air to pray
less he tells Kamala to skip stop signs
and fake looking in the mirror but the
first thing Kamala does on a driving
test after buckling in Mirror check with
the aviators it is clear that she is
thinking to herself hire for the faster
baby which may be also why she floors
the gas the driving instructor is played
by Randy Havens aka Mr Clark from
stranger things the directors of the
series say they were inspired by
Spider-Man into the spiderverse and like
that movie does the opening titles here
flash through more of kamalak Khan's art
showing a comic cover drawn by her
Jersey City Comics approved by the KK
code kamakan code I get a little nervous
when I see multiple KS back toback but
we'll look past that in this comic issue
she battles the something King and on
the page behind this are more drawings
showing Scott Lang and kamala's mutated
human man ant as kamala's parents drive
her home Mana says this is my fault this
is all my fault these are my genetics I
mean I come from a long line of
fantasizing on realistic Daydream my
mother was one yeah little clue here
pointing to Kamala and her mother's
family history specifically mana's
mother as the source of the powers that
Kamala gains Cala attends Cole's
academic High School where the founders
are all Comics writers and artists most
crucial to the creation of the Kamala
gon character of course G Willow Wilson
the Miss Marvel Comics writer I
mentioned before Steven Wacker Marvel
animated producer behind many of
kamala's comic team ups Adrien Alona an
artist on the first Calo run Jamie Melby
an artist who helped relaunch car
Danvers and designed Kamala Khan's first
M Marvel outfit Ian Herring known for
titles like Miss Marvel and silk
especially teshi miyazawa another artist
who worked on the Calo run Joe caranga a
Marvel Comics writer on several titles
over the years and niik Leon another
artist who worked on the Calo Comics I
love that they get a shout out here I
just you know hope that Disney pays them
all a little bonus too we meet kamala's
friends Bruno Carelli and Nakia bahadir
and the popular girl of school Zoe
Zimmer all of these from this particular
run of the comics around the score signs
reading Dustin for pre he is a be very
good choice Dustin Barry was the guy who
worked in the set department for the
show in a number of MCU titles Kamala
meets with guidance counselor Gabe
Wilson I assume named after G Willow
Wilson gww is written on his desk
organizer a quick Montage of kamala's
mishaps all show flashes of light the
DodgeBall hit the chemistry explosion
the sunlight beaming in on the art
teacher Camala is Blinded By the Light
at the beginning setting her up to
eventually control and master the light
Mr Wilson motivates Kamala with the
lyrics of Reflection from anulan not
going to lie High School staff could do
worse than just recite Disney lyrics to
kids he says I know fantasy's fun
fantasy's really fun but right now I
need you to pull yourself together and
join reality I like how this split
screen reflects how divided Cala is
right now staying grounded in reality or
escaping into her dreams and Fantasies
her path forward is in the ladder the
circle Q Shop shows up kamala's home
based in this run of the comics she and
Bruno plan to go to Avengers con which
is a lot like the AA celebration in The
Avengers game which leads to Kamala KH
getting her powers in San Francisco the
graffiti they bik passed all comes to
life it looks amazing visualizing their
final flourish pitches we see steampunk
Captain Marvel mashups Captain Panther
or iron Marvel they end up in a cat
fight then Doctor Strange Marvel who
comes in from a portal and makes that
same fann out arm pose as the images of
Icon spell that we saw in Infinity War
and the souls of the Damned in
Multiverse Madness then Captain Marvel
on a pegasus like Valkyrie rode in
endgame and Jane rides in Thor 4 then
princess Captain Marvel who changes the
graffiti W to shine then zombie Captain
Marvel her thumb falls off I love that
and when they are all rejected they all
look really sad like you can see
steampunk ghost taking her hat off
interesting how Cala watches an episode
of Felicity like where is that playing
on TV and syndication anywhere but then
kamala's upside down World Turns right
side up on this delivery from herani
showing how what's inside that box is
really the answer that will straighten
out her life the bangal an artifact that
manba has definitely seen before and
immediately tells air to hide in the
Attic when you think about it this whole
afternoon with Kamala and her mom must
have been unplanned like originally moo
was going to go wedding shopping with
air but she took Kamala to take kamala's
mind off of the bangal and off of her
grandmother now there are a lot of ways
we could read this bangal exactly what
it is for now could be an analog of the
create Nega band that transports marll
to the negative zone or maybe the
quantum bands worn by quazar to fire
energy blasts I actually think this is
some extraterrestrial tech there is some
indecipherable writing and a symbol that
looks like a star at burst but really
more importantly for Cala I think it's
something connected to her family
history they get home and greet Bruno
I'll back you something
no no I'm good how was it don't mention
Belgium or any guy named Rob did you ask
her about Avenger
card there's a spicy one at the bottom
for no now okay oh my gosh how did you
do that so fast whoa so I timed it out
Muna put that to-go bag together in 10
seconds if it's meant to be just a super
mom gag we don't really see Muna do this
anywhere else I'm just saying it could
just be a joke for the mom or the women
of this family might have something
going on with them her parents refus to
let her attend Avenger con and air
checks in on her asking if she's still
afraid of the Gin Gins are spirits and
demons in Arabic mythology the term and
concept later anglicized as Genie she
claims to no longer be afraid of the
dark but she does use a Starlight
projector thing in her bedroom don't
worry Camala having a healthy fear of
demons is just part of being a true
Marvel
fan the poster behind her bed shows
Captain Marvel from Jerry dodson's cover
of the comic Captain Marvel number five
it really just seems like they pulled
every awesome looking Comics image of
Captain Marvel and put it on her bedroom
walls I like how kamala's text appears
in the star lights of her feeling
whereas Bruno's response takes the form
of the Street Paint as the taxi drives
over it but in addition to the VFX
animation I like how they did this
practically by igniting the neon signs
in the store windows and then the LED
Marquee showing their ellipses and their
emojis kamala's Parents try to
compromise that Kamala can go to
Avengers con with her dad with her as
little Hulk him as big Hulk which I
would love to have my parents offer to
do this with me I don't think I'd find
it embarrassing but I get it Camala says
it'd be humiliating and there's a huge
missed opportunity here to have Yousef
sadly walk out to the 80s Hulk
theme
like yeah wouldn't that have been
awesome I mean they did use this track
in the 2008 Hulk
film Bruno references the time when
Camala fell into the Hudson river which
is something that happens to Zoe Zimmer
in the comics that leads to kamala's
First superpowered rescue Kamala and
Bruno sit on the roof their feet
dangling by an Iron Man sign but looks a
bit blurred and that might have been
because the show's producers were told
to tone down the numerous Iron Man
references they were going to make but
actually they look really closely you
can barely make out that this is really
an Iron Man themed cereal called iron
brand behind them is a sign for Edison
Electric with these bolt images which
might be teasing kamala's eventual logo
of a lightning bolt he gives her these
gloves for her cosplay are those Photon
gloves yeah yes photon is capitalized in
close captioning meaning that they are
referring to Monica Rambo Photon from
her mother Maria's call sign she goes by
both Photon and Spectrum in the comics
but W Vision never actually named her so
she's now confirmed as Photon and
apparently enough of a public figure for
Cala and Bruno to know about her and her
powers which is interesting now the
directors had this to say about the
photon Easter egg how do they know who
Monica Rambo is I want to ask you guys
thoughts on that yeah whenever we would
ask a question like that to Kev FY you
would say I don't ask
that we will see and discover like
anybody else because we would always say
so what happens in the Marvels
actually pass and and or or you know do
strange or in Spider-Man and he would
always say no if there's problem I'll
tell you and I don't tell you why just
stay in the world stay late so to me
that sounds like it might have been a
deliberate inclusion by the studio to
set up kamala's coming Crossover with
Monica and Carol Kamala breaks down her
elaborate plan to Bruno to get to
Avengers con and Her Fantasy her cosplay
is actual MCU wardrobe standard and she
does a black widow Landing outter window
the pose something that the show's
producers said Cala would know as one of
the few female superheroes she grew up
seen footage of Bruno in this fantasy
cosplays is Tony Stark wearing
sunglasses of goatee and a blowing chess
reactor Avenger con is at Camp Lehi
that's the New Jersey base where Steve
Rogers trained where Steven Black Widow
returned to a winter soldier and cap an
Tony visited in 1970 an endgame on the
bus in this fantasy are cosplayers of
the Star Spangled dancers and Loki and a
sorcerer with a shield among all the
fantasy selfies are a pipe are
cylindrical Rocket Raccoon a Nick Fury
Vision eating the pretzel and it ends
with Kamala dreaming of getting a tiara
something that she rejected earlier when
Bruno pitched princess Captain Marvel
and then the set transitions practically
into an upright bed which is the same
camera trick of the Nexus
anti-depressant commercial in W Division
and while kamala's plan ultimately goes
arise she does in the night dropping
into bed yes this dream plan immediately
falls apart instead of a superhero
Landing out her window she breaks the
tree branch and Falls hard that was the
way she was going to get back into her
room really the only way she's able to
get back into her window is with the
help of that hard light that she's later
able to summon poor Bruno even his
outfit doesn't look as cool we learned
later his whole cosplay is just a white
lap coat for Bruce Banner this poor guy
spent way more time making kamala's
cosplay suit than did his own we all
need friends like Bruno but instead we
don't talk about Bruno the camp Lehi
Banner is actually similar to the sign
at the gate when Tony and cap arrived in
1970 and end game they added cap shield
in the middle of it and I like how they
put this large statue of Captain America
in a jeep you're listening to the music
playing in the scene it is the Stars
Fang of man with the plan I like the
little dance that the guy in the
wakandan gar does to celebrate his
awesome looking fit inside the
convention booths include things Hulk
smashed which I guess is just a
collection of rubble and broken stuff
from all of Hulk's collateral damage
over the years you can see a fridge with
a giant handprint in it there's a giant
man Scot Lang display with a fairy in a
pool recreating his size up in the San
Francisco Bay an Ant-Man the WASP
there's a cosmic Avenger Captain Marvel
setup there's a realm of Asgard with a
Thor Throne that you can sit on we see
the Iron Man dancers from the Stark Expo
in Iron Man 2 mugs of Muir ale some art
pieces referencing America's ass I
understood that reference then there's a
memorial wall for the Fallen with
messages to various loved ones pinned up
to it in the middle is Natasha and Tony
on dis play but no vision also in the
upper right of all the notes is a
mention of the sovia Accords I assume
someone's saying this is why we need the
sovia Accords hey hey why you got to
make this so political bro there's
another Booth with the guy dressed as
draxx showing in a DVD on sale the Peter
Quill star boy story pal to all planets
a 40-minute documentary series I like
how the title calls him star boy keeping
up with a recurring gag of messing up
his name but isn't star Prince Star Lord
oh sorry presumably if quill himself
would have been the source for this they
probably would have gotten his name
right so I'm guessing this is a third
party trying to cash in on it also in
the background is a Shelf with rocket
plushies labeled trash pandas because
that's what he is he is a trash panda is
that better I don't know it's so much
worse another guy hands out pamphlets
for Avenger tours to new Asgard which
might be part of the tourist attractions
that we are now seeing in Thor love and
thunder footage now here's a fun one
after Camala leaves the bathroom there
is a cardboard Captain America and a
cardboard Iron Man on the left of the
frame which were actually cameos by Saga
Shake en Rish sha who play air and
Cameron thanks to Sager friend of the
show who actually sent me a photo of him
en Rish on set Kamala is able to unlock
the bangle by twisting a small circle
that turns four other cogs and then it
Clips on and extends then coats her body
with a layer of cosmic radiation and
then she falls backward into this
interesting purple tinted realm filled
with shadowy figures their eyes glowing
many of them look bald and caped
carrying Spears I don't know they look a
bit like Watchers a statue of whom
appears in Thor 4 now if this B Les
based on the cre Nega bands we might be
looking at the Negative Zone but I think
this is going to be more personal to
Kamala and her family her Nani the
purple infusa tones actually remind me a
lot of the ancestral plane which
moonight just told us is part of the
same MCU afterlife Network as the
Egyptian underworld we could be looking
at another spiritual realm that's
connected with the ancestors of the
Conan women ancestors who might be
extraterrestrial cre or srel or create
experiments on the humans the Inhumans
because in the comics Kamala gets her
powers by being enveloped in ter Mist a
process called terragenesis that creates
in humans and in her teren cocoon she
sees the forms of cat and Iron Man and
Captain Marvel and comes out in a form
modeled on her Idol Carol Danvers but
with stretchy limbs before she realizes
that she can just look like herself in
Marvel lore the Inhumans are genetic
experiments by the cre and in the MCU
the cre Supreme intelligence uses Tech
in which its form manifests based on the
perceiver's inner desires so kamala's
Cosmic powers from this Bengal may still
be cre or inhuman in origin but coming
to Kamala by way of her Pakistani
grandmother who maybe could have been an
extraterrestrial Refugee on Earth with
alien technology to harness the power of
the cosmos to manifest one's inner
desires in fact this layer of cosmic
radiation wisping around her body could
be the MCU version of terrien mist I'm
just doing my best to theorize how this
works we'll learn more in future
episodes now as she takes a stage light
is what triggers her powers to activate
the flashing camera and as she is
Blinded By the Light she emits a series
of crystalline discs what the show calls
hard light the same colors of the realm
she fell into now yes this is the change
from kamala's powers in the comics in
which she can stretch and Igan her limbs
like Reed Richards can but the producers
have said that they want to better align
MCU Kamala with where the MCU currently
is that seems to be either Cosmic
radiation of Captain Marvel and Photon
and the cre or maybe a kind of mystical
light inherited from her grandmother or
really again as I think a mix of the two
one blast of these knocks the giant Man
helmet loose so that this thing Boulders
through the convention rude gold buring
The Avengers boost so that a giant Muer
swings right into Zoe think about it for
Camala this is her worst nightmare
something that she did causing the
collapse of every avenger before her
eyes in the comics kamala's first hero
moment is saving Zoe and biging her hand
to lift her from the Hudson River here
she uses a cosmic extension of her hand
and arm to cushion Zoe's fall actually
in the closing credits of this episode
you could see an ambig version of
kamala's hand catching Zoe as it looks
in the comics the animation on the house
as Cala gets home shows the time as 1111
which is the time one makes a wish Anan
Kamala going through a bit of wish
fulfillment here her mother catches her
sneaky back in do you want to be
good like we raised you to be or or do
you want to be some you know this Cosmic
head in the clouds person and dropping
back down on her bed Camala answers
Cosmic yes this decision comes with
Camala falling backward just as she did
when she first snapped on that Bengal
and fell into her what I think ancestral
Nether world and when you think back to
the earlier scene this reaffirms her
accidental reverse on the driving test
as exactly the right direction for her
moving backward but really just to give
herself a Runway to launch into the
cosmos the closing credits have a few
more fun Easter eggs kamala's iconic red
Converses and her scarf from the comics
we see a trust abro moving truck from
Hawkeye and we see the same Kamala con
yellow bolt on purple t-shirt design
from the comics now there's a quick shot
of a skyscraper with the vestiges of the
Avengers Tower quinjet Landing Pad but
it's it's a new facade this is no longer
Avengers Tower I would say this could be
the Baxter building but Multiverse of
Madness showed the Baxter foundation in
Central Park then again that was 838
this is 616 even though Iman valani
vocally disagrees with Kevin pige on the
mcu's numerical designation I'm sorry we
love you Iman but I got to go with papae
on this one then onto a post credit
scene featuring The Return of Aran
moayed as dodc agent clear from
Spider-Man no way home last scene
interrogating Peter Parker NJ Ned and
ant May before Matt Murdoch was able to
get the dodc to drop the charges clear
and agent dver now see footage of Kamala
and decide to bring her in meaning this
series is going to shed some more light
on what the dodc is up to their
connections to Nick Fury and sword and
hopefully confirm my scroll suspicions
that agent clear might be a scroll
connected with Marvel's secret Invasion
plans his concerned looks suggests he
has seen this kind of Technology before
and if clear is a scroll he might be
seeing some cre weapons Tech emerging in
one of the cre sleeper cells Nick Fury a
AKA The Scroll Taos mentioned in
Spider-Man far from home remember cre
and scrolls are forever at War something
we'll probably learn more about in
secret Invasion and the next title
Kamala Khan is going to appear in the
Marvels so maybe now this look is
telling us that clear is seeing some
evidence of a cre Sleeper Cell with the
cre genetic experiments called Inhumans
which might be what Kamala Khan's
Pakistani ancestors were we will see and
I'm not sure how much to read into this
but under stever's phone on her desk are
wanted flyers for a Caucasian woman 58
brown hair 180 LB One in connection to a
double homicide on July 12th
1979 in the municipal graveyard 1979 is
ages ago in MCU history and my only
guess based on a graveyard slaying is
that this might tie into blades somehow
there are some photos on their board
showing some folks from older eras maybe
vampires are on their docket too this is
a breakdown of Miss Marvel episode 2
which teaches us all a little something
about pretending you're crushed is your
cousin when we're in the wish
fulfillment genre it may just come true
I hey we we don't know that for sure yet
which is exactly what we say of family
reunions down in the South let us break
down this episode shot by shot for all
the MCU Easter eggs and details you
missed notice how the s in the
previously on screen matches the S of
The Miz Marvel title in the comics and
in the series they intentionally styliz
that s to draw the eye to it make it
clear that she isn't Miss Marvel like
little Miss super hero but rather Miz an
independent woman in control of her own
life the episode opens on Kamala Str
back into her school to mes feel so good
the chorus to which is bad bad bad bad
boy you make me feel so good a little
tease of the bad bad boy ceran whom
Kamala will fall for this episode bad
bad boy with ulterior motives she wears
a Save Ferris button Save Ferris being a
Scot punk band who of course got its
name from the gag and Ferris peelers day
off where Ferris faked being deathly ill
to get out of school launching the Save
Ferris campaign while he rigged up a
stereo in his bedroom to fool his
parents similar to how Kamala tried to
use zuu to trick her parents into
thinking she was in her room she fools
around with a basketball echoing Andrew
Garfield Peter Parker's post PowerUp
moves and The Amazing Spider-Man but
then she bumps into camran knocking over
her chemistry textbook as we saw with
Peter and MJ smooching beside their
chemistry textbook it's a little on the
nose camaron wears the color blue and
with kamala's purple color tones there
definitely is some conscious wardrobe in
here as in the M Marvel Comics camaran
gets hit with the same teren Mist that
does transforming him into an inhuman
with blue colored bioluminescence where
he can release energy blasts or transfer
his energy into an object causing it to
glow and to explode this episode's
ending reveals kamran was targeting
Kamala from the very beginning in League
with his mother njma and I would not be
surprised if he actually bumped into her
on purpose here either to plant a
tracker on her maybe list something off
her or maybe just test her power
reflexes Camala tells Bruno I tried to
shrink and and and fly and talk to ants
and none of it worked wait what makes
you think you have am in Powers because
we're both charming and we look a lot
younger than we are an OD to actor Paul
Red's freakish agelessness and the fact
that in the MCU Scott Lang bypassed the
blip while he was in the quantum realm
making him older on paper than he is
biologically and at one point in end
game he did at the body of a baby and
the fact that all of these MCU actors
playing teenagers are several years
older in real life than their characters
are they passed this poster with a QR
code which is also something we saw in
many episodes of moonnight intentional
Easter egg snuck in there by the Marvel
Studios team because when you scan this
with your phone it actually takes you to
an issue from the 2014 Miss Marvel Run
actually this same QR code showed up in
episode one on the ATM in Bruno's Circle
Q store and last week that code took you
to miss Marvel number one from 2014 this
week the QR code takes you to number 15
of the 2014 Miz Marvel Run the issue
when Camala meets comron social media
star Zoe Zimmer quadrupled her followers
posting about her Rescue by Kamala on
Tik Tok and she brags about it here in
the cafeteria and then this like
beautiful white light like cascaded over
me I felt this wave of calmness like I
knew I was safe okay I don't want to
read in this too much and you know we're
all probably going to come around on Zoe
she's actually much nicer than she seems
right now but the one thing we know
about that hard light that saved her was
that it was not the color white it had
other colors in it I'm sorry Zoe I know
you didn't mean to say it but Zoe does
the name NightLight similar to
in far from home when Ned had to come up
with a superhero name and came up with
night monkey the opening titles of this
episode toggle through a bunch of
interesting designs first Miss Marvel as
brass knuckles the period on The Miz is
the same shape as the starburst icon on
her Bengal then her card dashboard then
a Donkey Kong style game and a night sky
with a crescent moon evoking the
moonnight title imagery and then one in
the style of Save By the Bell Camala
makes a fist how does it feel like an
idea come to life yeah another clue that
kamala's powers are a form of wish
fulfillment triggered by her inner
desires and thoughts also if this is
innate to Kamala Khan's DNA that makes
it even more likely she could be an
inhuman as she is in the comics but
rather than exposed to terar and Mist
herself she just may be the daughter
granddaughter and great- granddaughter
of Inhumans and activated by a piece of
creed Tech that could be what triggered
the terog Genesis process the mural by
the playground that they train at was
actual art created by New Orleans area
artist and activist B Mike Brandon odms
and then Kamala gets the idea from
watching Bruno play looks like the game
luy tale to used her hard light as a
lily pad Bruno's tablet impressively
tracks kamala's vitals and is able to
deduce from that that the power comes
from within her not from the Bengal
meaning that the Bengal really just
unlocked the power that was already in
her DNA from her family ancestry and
like we are wondering what that is Cal
begins to speculate so what am I like
Asgardian or something dude am I really
to Thor oh no I didn't say any of that
maybe wow Kamala is probably not an
Asgardian like Thor is she may be
something else extraterrestrial in
origin like an inhuman experiment by the
alien race of the Creed she and Bruno
noticed some writing on her bangle
Kamala thinking it's either Arabic or
maybe Urdu but from our Spanish point
it's not clear if they were talking
about the symbols on the green bands or
somewhere else on this bangle but for
reference we do know the alphabets for
the cre in the scroll languages and
we've also seen the written language of
Zen Darian in the Guardians of the
Galaxy movies so Cala experiments with
this Lily padding on this hard light she
hangs from the ledge by that iron brand
poster that we saw last episode this
fake out with her and Bruno acting like
she was going to fall off the building
just for her to drop a few feet
definitely reads like restaging of
Natasha's death and endgame with Bruno
playing the platonic ideal best friend
Clint I assume an account of this would
have been in an episode of Scott Lang's
podcast for Natasha to now be on a
memorial poster in Avengers con I would
hope that Cala would take a moment of
silence and she eventually gets the hang
of it the shot framing her within the
bolt of the neon Edison sign just a cool
way of showing that she is now in
control of the hard light if you think
about it that is kind of what a neon
sign is it's light but it but but but
it's hard it's hard now of course in
order to accomplish the stunt of this
shot they had someone on a green screen
set and then VFX them onto this roof
which is why that little celebr atory
yes at the end just looks a little weird
oh and this Edison sign by the way is a
reference to the inventor that was
Kamala Khan's first real villain in the
2014 Comics a cockail bird possessed
with the consciousness of a clone of
Thomas Edison actually that cockail bird
we saw among Kamala Khan's drawings in
the open in imagery of episode 1 was
also a nod to that guy it's a little too
wacky of a concept probably for this
show but I'm so glad that they pay
homage to him this way Kamala and Nakia
are late to mosque services and we learn
how the women's section of this mosque
is less maintained we get some crumbling
tiles in the bathroom mold under the
carpet less security around the women's
shoe racks because poor Nakia gets her
shoes stolen maybe whoever that squirrel
was who stole Nick Fury shoes on the
squirrel space station got my shoes
Scrolls might have a thing about
stealing shoes and we laugh about that
but I I do think scrolls are going to
show up in the show at least I hope they
will and my favorite detail this episode
later when Kamala saves that kid from
falling we get a closeup of the shoes
and what do you know it was this twerp
who stole nakia's shoes the women of
this mosque have to deal with enough kid
onto Zoe's party which becomes a pool
party because Cameron does a high jump
into the pool super weird to do even
though this pool is heated because it is
freaking cold outside they're all
wearing coats they have these heater
lamps and now poor Cameron's going to be
stuck in wet clothes all night as he
leaves this pool you can see some blue
lights and Blue Mist steaming around him
definitely evoking that bioluminescent
form from the comics actually later
during kamala's Fantasy sequence she
envisions herself in purple neon and
Camron in blue neon maybe a nod to them
both being bioluminescent in humans I
like how poor jealous Bruno tries to
subvert Cameron's coolness you really
belly flopped back there man that that
had to hurt don't think so really feel a
thing nice try bro ain't going to happen
why because Cameron clearly has some
oddly inhuman properties to his body and
Kamala Flirt by discussing their
favorite Bollywood films referencing srk
that of course is the great sha ruk Khan
massive Bollywood movie star and they
also mentioned two of his biggest titles
Bazar from 1993 and ddlj from 1995 five
he gives her his number but again as
sweet as this seems it is too good to be
true comron has alterior motives and was
clearly assigned by his mother to get
close to Camala Bruno was right to be
suspicious if things are too good to be
true they often are but poor Kamala
doesn't know that yet because she is
smitten the lens dissolves into the
lights all forming these heart shapes
and then we get this adorable dance
number to the rett's be my baby and
again because it's my job to ruin
wholesome things Be My Baby sung by
Ronnie Spectre produced by Phil Spectre
Phil Spectre was married to her into did
horrible horrible things to her look it
up so as sweet as things seem on the
surface there is actually A Dark Truth
behind them now last episode we saw a
similar fantasy sequence From kamala's
perspective of her whole family all
dancing and celebration of Kamala but
now notice it is only Kamala dancing as
her parents watch on from the kitchen
confused Kamala is joined only by the
beautiful vibrant lights now filling the
house because kamala's core relationship
in the series is really a dance between
her and her lights this fantasy turns to
Neon forms of her and Camron drifting
off in his space joined by two astronaut
sloth babies this transitions to cala
daydreaming at her desk and her nose
suddenly glows an analogous scenario to
getting that surprise zit on your nose
in the middle of a school day naturally
leading to Nakia what a great friend
handing her a tampon and by the way I
hope this was not the reason why this
show was randomly rated tv14 because you
really think kids younger than 14 aren't
also going through this kind of thing Mr
Wilson tells Bruno that he got into
early admission at Caltech but Bruno
isn't sure about jumping on this
opportunity you know that part in the
movie where someone comes in to the main
character and they say you want to be a
Jedi or you want to answer phones of a
demanding but impossibly Chic magazine
editor as before Mr Wilson only knows
how to speak to these kids in movie
references and in this case Star Wars
and the devil we's pru but despite
knowing so much about movies Wilson is
failing to acknowledge that a classic
step in every protagonist journey is the
refusal of the call Luke Skywalker
rejects obiwankenobi initially and only
leaves stne once his aunt and uncle are
killed and de wor brada Andy initially
walks out of the interview with Miranda
Priestley thinking she blew the
interview and tries to quit several
times before finally deciding to take
the job seriously so Bruno is at the
refusal of the call stage let Bruno have
his Beats so after school Camron Waits
For Her by his sweet ride and notice how
the sun glares off the hood blinding her
with the light again last episode all
these lens flares blinding lights
representing Kamala being distracted and
I love the blocking here Bruno blocks
that light gives her a relieving shade
trying to keep her away from this bad
bad boy and shielding her from the
blinding light also you'll notice how
Bruno wears a blue shirt and a red vest
which is not to the comics when Camala
had a kid who sat behind her in class
dressed up as Marty McFly who doodled
Team Wolf in his notebook caman and
Kamala chat some more about Bollywood
Stars M's the same she still has a huge
crush on Kingo Senor e concerning very
they're referring to the movies of Kingo
Kam Nani's character in eternals a
Bollywood star who would reinvent
himself as a younger generation era
after era caman goes on to say yeah I
mean it must be a generational thing cuz
I don't really understand half the
things my mom's into to a very important
line when you consider the context that
Cameron may be a generational inhuman as
well their ancestors having an
extraterrestrial link maybe njma was
into Kingo knowing he is an ageless
Eternal not originally from Earth
pretending she is much younger than she
really is is something that she also
does Amir catches them just comron he's
our cousin our
cousin the ending of this episode does
imply that they may actually be related
hopefully he is adopted because
otherwise why are you getting on her
like that dude at dinner Yousef says
that's why we moved to America right so
that our children could be anything that
they wanted to be almost anything yes
this is a common hope of all immigrants
but might have a deeper context if Mana
doesn't want Kamala to be a cosmically
powered inhuman Yousef goes on to say
Mona's family moved to Karachi only
after the partition back then there was
no Pakistan or Bangladesh it was all one
big country India after the British just
the British left us with a mess so the
partition refers to when Great Britain
parted ways with British India in 1947
and the subcontinent divided into India
and Pakistan separating the military the
Civil Service Railways treasury millions
of people along religious lines Muslims
to Pakistan Hindus to India displacing
10 to 20 million people causing horrible
ethnic violence resulting in deaths
estimated from several hundred thousand
people to 2 million people it was a
horrible dark time one of the worst
Refugee crises we've seen in human
history youf explains how mana's mother
was caught up in all that a on the last
train out of a station and got separated
from her parents nobody knows how a
little toddler sa managed to get back on
the train just before the train pulled
out of the station I like how Amir
completes this part of the story but
then Yousef turns to Kamala to finish
the second part of the story about how
the toddler made it back to her father
she followed a trail of stars right back
to her
[Music]
father and I like how there's some
subtle musical Chimes here like it was
some Cosmic magic at play in this
history a trail of stars referring to
Cosmic intervention cre Tech Inhumans
that Sana and her mother Aisha used to
survive maybe even a cre Starship
transporting her back to her father
trail of stars also sounds like
something America Chavez might have
helped out with using a path of star
portals to teleport Sana back to her
father now this would have been almost
80 years prior I'm not really sure how
aging Works in other dimensions like the
utopian parallel but it's just worth
bringing up tra Stars you know but when
Yousef mentions that mana's mother
disappeared the bangal glows a white
portal opens and kamala's eyes glow
purple as they did last episode when she
was transported to that other realm in
this case a woman appears with a purple
tinted face and this is narsha's
character credited as najma I'm thinking
also kamala's great-grandmother Aisha
that kamala's Nani Aisha's daughter said
previously owned this bangle and the
purple color on her face could make her
one of those purple entities from
kamala's Vision I believe all of them
representing Aisha's other inhuman
family and Kamala 's broader ancestry
network but listen closely to the sound
effects here you can hear a train
whistle there is also the sound of a
train under najma in the back seat in
the final
shot both of these train sounds could be
a not to Aisha getting separated from
Sana and sana's father at that train
station and Aisha later helping Sana
find him using that trail of stars now
later in this episode The illumines will
gossip about Aisha my father called her
a snake she put a curse on everything
she touched I heard that she had a
secret affair and took off with someone
I heard she had many Affairs and she had
a secret family I heard she killed a man
happening partition yes just some hot
Goss of course but it might be rooted in
truth just from a different point of
view like Aisha may have had another
family of Inhumans she might have killed
someone in self-defense and her powers
back then probably were viewed as a
curse or some kind of superstition I
just love how this series grounds
kamala's family history in the partition
between between India and Pakistan real
world history when many lives were lost
many families were separated and many at
that point in history were ostracized as
others something that could apply doubly
to Aisha as an inhuman in the' 40s that
would stir up these rumors and
superstitions about her in that
Community leading to her just getting
separated during the partition and
letting her family go so they could have
a normal life yet still an inhuman Gene
would have been left in the women of
this family a legacy that manba fears as
a curse feeling shame over it but now
Kamala has it and it has been activated
they attend the Eid festival at their
mosque or Eid alada Cala jokes with
Nakia and Bruno about the illuminatis
the illuminatis actually they know
everything we later meet them and
nakia's breakdown of the different
groups of this community which is just
pretty interesting timing for Multiverse
of Manis to introduce us to the 838
Illuminati I would love it if this is
the Illuminati of the 616 universe and
here in the animated title the a is the
allseeing ey of the Illuminati
conspiracy theory we also meet the
mosque Bros which actually includes a
cameo by Bal fah the co-director of
episode 1 and episode 6 six then the
pious boys have the same hands together
image as kamala's bismal drawing in
episode one but notice how the hands
separate to reflect that Gap that Nakia
refers to and then the insta click has
Instagram labels like tag blessed Dean
Dean being a term in Islam or stain
devout under Allah then dodc agent clear
interrogates Zoe you're not the Zoe
Zimmer the only one I know what you have
got to be kidding me I'm a big fan wait
really yes everyone in the office is
yeah clearly knows that flattery is
everything to you suspects similar to
how he's able to get NED to confess his
role in no way home but of course his
tone shifts and then the uh enhanced
individual tried to kill you aha
enhanced that was the code term that the
MCU used in place of mutants back in Age
of Ultron in this case it seems to be a
catch-all term for any Rogue
superpowered person mutant inhuman super
soldier Hulk anyone beneath the tiar of
Sam Wilson's big three what big three
Androids aliens and wizards but then
agent dver joins interrogation and did
she have an accent of any kind was she
Latina I'm sorry I'm supposed to say
latinx now right Middle
Eastern South Asian yeah clear's
expression suggests he objects to this
kind of racial profiling but then he
says let's do the Tri-State sweep search
every Temple Community Center
and and mosque just be respectful the
FBI is already surveilling let me know
that they do leave Aran moayed off
screen but you can hear in his delivery
a bit of hesitation right before he says
mosque and then they include the mention
of the FBI because yeah since 9/11 the
FBI has been monitoring mosques in
Muslim community centers all over the
country a shift from the bureau's focus
on domestic terrorism in the 90s after
the Oklahoma City bombings and wouldn't
you know it that white nationalism
didn't go anywhere at the festival a kid
hangs from the tower so Camala has to
suit up and cosplay to save him I love
how she tries to calm him down what do
do you have a favorite food ice cream
pizza did someone say ice cream pizza I
love how nja the vendor just got an idea
for a new food to sell this guy better
be selling ice cream pizza next episode
Cala lily pads over to him and tries to
catch him but when the hard light gives
out she has to form another Landing Pad
saving the day we think hoppy and off
forming another pose just like her
fantasy self did in episode one copying
Black Widow we see a frenzy of social
media posts about this rescue also
commenting on the hilarious combination
of pizza and ice cream I'd love all
these memes but they include one from
Frogman jewels and we will see Frogman
and She-Hulk Eugene patio as that
goofball in the spring-loaded frog suit
that he got from his father this angle
of this photo of alala falling is from
above with the hard light below her so
Frogman must have been leaping over them
to get this photo of this moment doing
nothing to save them but then again we
also don't know if these memes are
actually in real life or just kamala's
imagination of how she thinks everyone
will love her because of this probably
the latter but kamala's concentration is
broken when her great-grandmother
appears to her so the hard light
flickers out and the kid falls again
kamala's imant hand fails to catch him
so she has to slow his fall with just
more hard platforms leading to a pretty
hard
Landing my
ankle oh come on kid you already know
it's your ankle kid trying to get Cala a
yellow card Camala faces a drone that
looks like a dark painted customized
Stark drone from Spider-Man far from
home and no way home also Cameo to
Multiverse amadas remember that that was
weird now remember the dodc and other
agencies confiscated these drones so
they would be in possession of them but
they don't necessarily have full control
over Tony's Edith software which might
be why the drone's inner interface looks
different than it did in Far From Home
dver shows up with dodc agent armed with
these handheld Sonic cannons this should
look familiar to you this is more Stark
Tech first seen in the 2008 Hulk film it
was a Stark Industries design when they
used it on the Virginia campus but Tony
also added these to war machines armor
in Civil War when he used it on wand
maximoff these were also on the Stark
drones and Far From Home blowing Peter
off of tower bridge and we see these
same guns in the She-Hulk trailer
suggesting it is a dodc there in that
show also a crazy detail in episode one
if you're looking closely looks like
there is a photo of Jamila jam on the
dodc wanted posters in that post credit
scene Jamil is playing the super villain
Titania in She-Hulk so since we see
these guns in the She-Hulk trailer that
might mean the dodc is the same agency
that Jennifer Walters is dealing with in
that series and if Matt Murdoch dealt
with a dodc in no way home it's just one
more way Daredevil could cross over into
She-Hulk it's all connected Camala
wrecks these drones just as effectively
as Peter Parker did but the Sonic Cannon
obliterates her hard light making it
look so brittle and I think this hard
light is actually meant to look wrinkled
increased to deler deliberately evoke
papier-mâché as if this is glowing
papier-mâché as kamala's Powers were
activated while she was wearing
papier-mâché Captain marble cosplay as I
explained in my video where I
interviewed the directors this form of
kamala's powers is intended to be a
temporary look that Cala will evolve
past and I think this hard light is
really pieces of her teragen cocoon that
she's gradually shedding off until she
reaches her final form Cameron's timing
is amazing as he swoops in a pick her up
but in the back seat is a ghost Camala
I've been waiting a very long time to
meet you it's all
connected because if najma aka the woman
from the Visions is kamala's great
grandmother Aisha if she's also
Cameron's mother that would make Cameron
kamala's grandmother's brother or half
brother if he was born to a different
father but still Cameron might be
kamala's grand Uncle Thor hook up Kamala
with an escape here he's adopted now of
course it is very odd that njma is still
relatively young if she's her
great-grandmother from the' 40s she
should be older right well njma may
instead just be a sister or cousin to
maniva who just looks a lot like their
great-grandmother might still be a
relative that miva left behind in
Pakistan who in that case would make
kamron kamala's cousin but no I don't
think so najma looks exactly the same to
these visions and in those Visions she
wore older clothes had an older
hairstyle so I think njma is the same
person as Aisha and the agelessness is
because she is an inhuman the curse that
the illumines were talking about njma
and kran might be Inhumans Inhumans are
known to live two to three times longer
than humans are age more slowly now now
I know you might say eternals don't age
at all and KRON did mention najma liked
Kingo movies I just doubt that these
characters would be ideed as eternals as
well there were only 10 eternals on the
planet they were synthetic aliens They
Don't Really reproduce or anything I
really just think njma liked Kingo
because she identified another ageless
figure hiding in public of course
another possibility to consider is that
njma might just be a scroll taking on
the identity of Aisha's appearance the
rumors that she was the snake could come
from Aisha having a scroll partner that
she would trade places with the way Fury
and Taos have a partnership since in the
comics kamran actually serves a villain
called lineage najah here might be this
Show's version of that character it just
remains to be seen whether she is truly
villainous or someone who's actually
trying to help her but also we should
point out Carol danver's cosmic power up
and ensuing cre transfusions left her in
a state in which she didn't really age
from 1995 to 2023 so all of this might
just be a symptom of cre Tech and Cosmic
radiation and I just think it's so
ironic that Kamala began this episode
joking about how like Ant-Man she looks
younger than she really is is and now
that seems to be a genetic trait that
she inherited this is a breakdown of M
Marvel episode 3 which gives Camala 10
Rings problems in a genate one I don't
know if that made sense but let's break
down this episode shop by shop for all
the Marvel Easter eggs and details you
might have missed cuz there is so much
to explain from the opening minutes of
this episode we open in British occupied
India in 1942 making this a few years
before the partition mentioned last
episode that's when the British left
India by dividing it into India and
Pakistan resulting in devastating civil
unrest we find ourselves in a cave
containing various ancient relics
digging through this Rubble is najma
Faria Saleem and kamala's long lost
great grandmother Aisha I found the
bangle should we be concerned it's on a
seadon you heard what that man from the
temple said he said we would need two so
where's the other one I told you the
bries have probably looted this place
twice over by now and as the British
army realizes their intrusion they
burned down this location and we get
this overhead shot revealing the the
floor is carved with the symbol of the
10 Rings woo boy but really the key
detail here is that they find this
bangle on a severed blue arm which
indicates to us that it may be cre cre
are humanoid extraterrestrials in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe many of whom
are blue skinned cre being the society
that Carol Danver is ended up with and
Captain Marvel most of them are
imperialist Pricks cre technology is
partially the source of Carol Denver's
power up it was a light speed engine
powered by the tessera the space Stone
followed by a bit of cre transfusion it
was the cre who invented the ter the
process that creates Inhumans and what
gave Cala her powers in the comics so
this 10 Rings logo might mark this as a
location when wo discovered the 10 rings
in the comics the 10 rings are alien
mclan technology discovered by the
Mandarin in the wreckage of a mclan ship
the shanii film only hints at where wi
Wu found these
[Music]
rings
so this place may be that tomb or Crater
where when wo found the rings that these
Rings were extraterrestrial technology
but not from the mouans like they are in
the comics but in the MCU from the cre
this could be a cre crash site
containing other relics of ancient cre
technology this group sent here by a man
in the temple whom I believe to be win
woo win woo has had the Rings for over a
thousand years and this helmet that FIA
finds looks like the kind worn by the
tin Rings Cavalry in that shuni prologue
or at least worn by an army that they
conquered we are in the Indian
subcontinent here but the tin Rings
Empire spanned the whole Asian continent
from China to Afghanistan many have
speculated that Bengal is connected to
the T Rings because if you look closely
it does illuminate very similarly to the
way the tin rings do remember in the
shuni post credit scene Wong banner and
Carol daners analyze those rings they're
not
vibranium
chitauri not like any alien Tech I've
seen how long did your dad have them
before he gave them to you about a
thousand years the thermal luminesence
indicates they're older than that now
Carol might be familiar with modern
crech but if these Rings were ancient
crech it would predate any expertise
that she had so I believe ancient cre
sent a dispatch to Earth thousands of
years ago perhaps alerted by the arrival
of the eternals or maybe the even
earlier arrival of a vibranium meteorite
to wakanda which I think was the nextest
moment that really gave the true birth
of civilization and technology to this
planet in the MCU I think that ancient
Creed dispatch could have brought with
them the 10 rings and the two Bengals
maybe also technology like Tera Genesis
sometime after that the Rings were
recovered by win woo maybe there was
some kind of conflict where he severed
the arm of that warrior with the Bengals
so why now would win wo give this group
valuable information maybe it wasn't win
woo maybe it was a rival of his but
remember in chungi non explained the
realm of talo we have cities that
surpass any in your Universe rich with
culture and history thousands of years
ago all of our people lived in peace and
prosperity until the attack of the
dweller in darkness so this implies that
the dweller of Darkness must have come
from some Dimension Beyond talo as these
folks are interdimensional beings from
Beyond when wo might have made a deal
with these Devils for him to keep the 10
rings so that they could take the bangal
now the most important detail from that
postcard had scene was that the 10 Rings
were released in some kind of pulsing
Beacon that was summoning something or
someone now I think it will be revealed
to be the cre as the rightful owners of
this technology this being a very
important Relic to their culture and
with secret Invasion coming up I think
we're going to learn about the cre
squirrel Shadow War that's been
happening behind the scenes and that's
going to erupt into an allout Cosmic war
in which Carol Kamala and Monica are
going to have to defend Earth from a cre
Invasion I think that is going to be the
plotline of the marbles next year so
where is the other bangal Faria says the
British had already looted this tomb
which is an important clue it could be
in one of those London museums we
visited recently where Cersei and danne
worked or where Steven Grant worked or
where kilmonger visited that Relic could
be among the possessions of danne's
Uncle along with the Ebony Blade that we
saw in the eternals post credit scene it
could be an artifact held by mi3 the
supernatural investigation division
where blade and black knight have both
worked and we know the two of them are
now together from that post-edit scene
or it could be in damage control storage
along with the chitari tech and the
Ultron heads that we saw in Spider-Man
homecoming Aisha snaps on this angle her
eyes turned purple as they did for
Camala presumably she got a glimpse of
that nor Dimension as Camala did but
because Aisha was from that Dimension
she cannot fully connect with this
Bengal the way Kamala can since she was
born in this Dimension and then we jump
to the present where we realize najma
has been telling this story to Kamala
and najma reveals that she and Aisha and
the others were exiled from another
dimension called the nor Dimension nor
meaning light and they all have some
degree of nor in them but in lesser
quantities still slowing down their
aging however Camron is 17 years old so
don't worry no one's going to jail well
he does go to jail this episode but you
know not for that njma says the bangle
helped Kamala unlock her no and maybe
someday something will help camran
unlock his hinting that he will probably
power up into his blue bioluminescent in
human form from the comics then we meet
the last one of their group who's only
hinted at in the opening scene his name
is
adamn don't mind him we've been around
for 100 years and he picks the stupidest
parts of humanity to be obsessed with
that's so rude his name being Adam is
significant as when they argue off
screen the caption show he says this is
his house he's more confident than the
others and there might be some
significance to that because njma says
in our home
Dimension the new dimension were known
as the clandestines as to what we are
we've been called aabi Maj unseen the
list goes on but what most commonly
known as is Jin I'm sorry did you just
say Jin okay wow so the term Jin was was
actually mentioned back in episode one
please tell Bruno the zuu is possessed
by the evil Jin he needs to fix it Jin
refers to a spirit or a demon in Islamic
mythology actually pre-islamic mythology
as Yousef clears up later they've been
anglicized as Genies which basically
just means white cultures has
bastardized this culture they've turned
the concept into like jacked blue Will
Smith rapping but Jin absolutely have a
deeper lore to them the idea is that
whereas humans were understood to be
made from clay the Jin was made from
smokeless fire and are forbidden to
interact with humans and are actually
invisible To Us by the the other terms
that njma mentioned ajnabi is Arabic for
strange alien or foreign majnun is
Turkish for a crazy person unseen may
have a deeper meaning to it Marvel lore
unseen has been considered to be
invisible to the Watchers but I think
she was using it in the context that
Jinn are supposed to be invisible to
Mortals but the key word there was
clandestine which was capitalized and I
think might be referring to a lesser
known group in Marvel Comics from the 9s
founded by Adam of ravencroft Adam later
dubbed Adam of Destin from 12th century
England who during the Crusades fell in
love with a Jin their descendants become
the clandestine all with various
different powers and they team up with
the X-Men and don't feel bad if you
don't know they existed because they
were never popular I guarantee you even
the nerdiest Marvel fan who watched this
episode today had to do a bit of
Googling to figure out who these guys
were but I think that was by Design
their obscurity and their intersection
with Jin mythology being the reason why
this term was chosen here now to be
clear this group is only 100 years old
really it's their extra dimensional
status and the fact that they identify
with being Jin something important in
pre-islamic mythology being far more
important to who they are in this story
the fact that the biggest a-hole in the
group is named Adam I think just a nod
to Adam of ravencroft Adam of destine
I'm thinking that their nor Dimension is
actually another spiritual afterlife
realm in the MCU alongside the ancestral
plane in the datat As tarat and moonight
explained that both the datat and the
ancestral plane were part of an array of
interlined after lives that all take
different forms based on the beliefs of
the individual and now to be clear the
concept of the Jin far predates 100
years years when these Exiles arrived
into our Dimension so really Jin is just
what they were called and how they
explain what they are but they are not
literally Jin and it remains a mystery
why they were exiled and what it says
about that Dimension that authorities
there Exile Souls from that realm and
leave us with them what I love most
about all this is that it is grounding
the mythology of Kamala Khan and the
whole Khan family and her powers in
faith that seems to be a thematic
undercurrent of phase 4 with stories
like Thor love and thunder eternals
moonnight and soon black panther will
forever all exploring the themee of how
for many of these characters being a
superhero is deeply intertwined with
their spiritual beliefs and I think this
is awesome because the MCU may be about
to establish that all paranormal
folklore beings in this world vampires
ghosts demons werewolves bigfoots
chupaco musks are Exiles from other
spiritual Realms other dimensions and
assuming one of those Dimensions is hell
because we got a pretty good look at
that in dror strange in the Multiverse
of Madness you know what that means not
today though now the opening title
includes kamala's notepad drawing
showing Captain Marvel with a heart on
her chest Iron Man with a heart on his
chest and palm repulser Hulk and then
this sexy dude going oh hi another is
cut paper with k k labeled on the
scissors and then another is a drawing
of Camala totally falling over comun
also a quick reminder that the best way
to support new rockstars is to get our M
Marvel inspired Cosmic Daydream shirt at
new rockstars merch.com where you'll get
the added option to ride in a custom
shout out for our Miz Marvel after shows
Kamala tries to explain this all to
Bruno I'm
a onic solid joke I love it the books on
Bruno's shelf include mechanical
behavior of materials turning the wheel
hacking Darwin how to manage your mother
how the mind works Mr monster and on top
of an issue of Popular Science Cala asks
do you know anything about
interdimensional travel off the top of
your head specifically the nor Dimension
that's n o actually no that reminds me
of a paper I read uh I think it's by Dr
Eric selv perfect yes Eric selig Thor
and Jane Fosters astrophysicist buddy
from the Thor films and Age of Ultron
and now based on the inflate movies and
Spider-Man far from home something of a
Neil degrass Tyson figure in the MCU
Bruno shows Kamala that she's trending
that Tik Tok post from a guy named
Miguel with hashtags including mosque
save girl on roof NightLight and Jersey
City hero dodc agent diver's license
plate is 0102 e in One Vision Wanda and
vision's license plate when they first
drove into Westview in episode one was
0102 she struts into the mosque her
shoes making hard thuds on that
carpeting just so rude of her in these
agents to enter with their shoes on
Nakia tells them to get a warrant
mosque board member we still have few
more vs to count okay all right
perspective member but I feel good about
our polling yeah there is a lot of ADR
in this episode that's where they bring
in actors afterwards to dub in audio
that they just kind of layer in in
postproduction and by the way they do
that all the time in movies and TV shows
usually it's very subtle but this one
was totally my favorite nakia's
political rival wanting to make sure all
the votes were counted a detail that I
love because if you think about it
kamala's rescue in the Eid Festival when
they campaigned was the day before so
when was this election ction held during
the festival this morning at the meeting
how many people voted how long were the
polls open I mean this guy is totally
right to demand some election security
here Camala watches a Tik Tok video on
her desktop that's weird the comments
include a bunch of little Easter eggs
including one from Queen XA she could
save me anytime one from Royal Ruby
NightLight saves people left and right
the real Euro King saying Captain Marvel
wannabe now I assume this is actually
naaf the Euro vendor humy drizzle
replies to him saying yeah she can't
even fly yurri King also comments I
don't know what everyone is so hyped
about she broke the kid's leg but then
beneath that gww not the bridge defends
her saying she saved him he would have
fallen without her now gww could refer
to M Marvel co-creator G Willow Wilson
or maybe the guidance counselor Mr
Wilson named after her and then there's
a comment from fison the man and the
real Zoe Zimmer oh Zoe you always just
got to be where it's happening don't you
outside of the party Cala has this
heart-to- heart with herik who advises
good it's not a thing you are
Kamala it is a thing you do yes
reminding Camala that her status as a
great- granddaughter of a clandestine is
really irrelevant it's her own choices
now that Define her we see Bruno has
given Cala a superhero mask and he put
it in a shoe box if you look at the side
of that shoe box it is size 13 men damn
Bruno in the circle Q Bruno studies
selvig's paper on his laptop and you can
see an Einstein Rosen Bridge
illustration AKA a wormhole and he
refers to the events of New York City in
2012 aka the Battle of New York
something he was very involved with
considering Loki use a mindstone on him
there's also some language asking if we
should leave this Dimension or not Dr
Selvig doing the work that soon
characters like Reed Richards and Kang
will be building on Yousef drops in for
a hostess fruit pie which is a classic
Marvel Comics deep cut for when like
Spider-Man or The Avengers would
randomly plug Hostess fruit pies in
panels a very forced and cringey thing
that Marvel Comics used to do as Ed of
hints out with this meta line there just
something about their
synthetic I just can't resist them
Yousef translates some erdu text about
the Jin Legend tells of a group of
hidden Jin exiled from their home world
and Damned to live out their days
trapped in our own they move in Shadows
searching for the key that will help
them get home but to unlock such an
ancient barrier will require a
primordial power later with Bruno camalo
wears an Iron Man shirt and rubs her
knee telling us that her nor doesn't
necessarily give her rapid healing
powers Bruno tells her that they'd need
the energy the size of the sun to open a
portal through Dimensions which could
wreak havoc on this Dimension Kamala
says Carol dver want to wait she'd punch
a hole in space in time and she'd help
them now and Carol ders would be
Reckless maybe it's not such a bad thing
that you're not her yeah I'm so glad
someone said it Avengers including
Captain Marvel are not good Role Models
higher fast further baby also I'm sorry
I burned the city down oh well when
Kamala texts comr on a QR code appears
to her left on the wall every episode
there is a hidden QR code somewhere in
the shot where if you scan it with your
phone it'll take you to a link that
actually updates every week with a new
free m Marvel comic and this week it's
the Magnificent M Marvel number one from
2019 which frames Cala as a bedtime
story hero called the destined one this
episode's title is destined all the
story beats this episode with the family
wedding all the heart to Hearts between
mana and Kamala between YF and Amir
they're all just so wholesome and sweet
and wonderful we get to learn so much
about the family in the culture and it
is a delight one detail that I really
liked is air being shoeless throughout
the event this is actually a game ritual
called juta chupai in which the groom's
shoes are stolen and the gro must beg or
pay Ransom to get them back before he
can leave the venue my dumb Theory this
week is that Nick Fury got his shoes
stolen on the scroll space station
because he was currently getting married
that day to a South Asian woman probably
wrong probably wrong I just want to know
why they took his shoes and during the
amazing dance sequences the'll knows the
nephew is wearing the padded Hulk outfit
the Mana stitched for Kamala and youf an
episode episode one The Wedding Band is
brown Joy a bon JY cover band calling
back the family's love of the New Jersey
prince in the past episode comron shows
up to warn Kamala but also to screw over
Bruno he knows his name isn't Brian
there's a legitimate jealousy there and
as I mentioned before some of his lines
here were definitely picked up later via
ADR kill everyone you have to get out of
him hey think you should leave Cala
everyone will die I am guessing that an
earlier cut of this episode didn't
properly have Camron establishing the
life or death Stakes of najma's crew but
also are they going to K everyone we
don't really know what the clandestine
power set was they don't really seem
that scary a lot of this part seemed a
bit hastily edited together but still
there's a lot to love here like the
amazing needle drop to have bon jovis
Living on a Prayer during this chaos
this whole episode establishes kamala's
Powers as grounded in her spiritual
beliefs she is literally Living on a
Prayer now at first actually thought
Brown Joby kept playing through this
which would be nuts but you can see them
running off in the chaos but still that
means they set their break music to
continue to play and those break tracks
are all Bon chovi songs which is also
really funny another little detail here
after worrying about not having enough
money in his bank account during this
Panic Amir smartly goes for the cash and
grabs it off the plate the clandestines
turn out to be a real bunch of a-holes
Adam straight up punches a cook who
wasn't even in his
way absolutely not no I love that extra
give her a spin-off there are some goofy
signs posted throughout this kitchen
like on the dry erase board 63 days
without incident how bad was that in
where they had to keep track of their
days without one then a teal sign on the
walk-in cooler that says please do not
enter this cooler unless you
specifically need something in here this
cooler is to remain locked at all times
whoa yikes I assume they also meant to
put up a sign that says also please
refrain from saying the words longing
rusted furnace Daybreak because we keep
Winter Soldiers Frozen in here what the
hell and yes we do not really get a
clear sense of the clandestine power set
they seem to have some super strength
like they crack the floor tile and send
Camala flying after they punch her nor
Shield Adam Taps a chest pendant trans
forming it into a melee weapon but that
shot is so dimly lit that we can't
really make out this Transfiguration Bia
just shows up with a spear Seline turns
its belt into this whip-like blade I
think this is actually a bendable blade
called narumi Kaman and njma both have
weapons but we don't really see where
they tap them from I mean hey it
wouldn't be Disney Plus without a a
midseason moment right it especially
just feels a little lame when they can
all get taken out by dodc Hulk Sonic
cannons and then get arrested like
Scooby-Doo villains I mean no offense to
these clandestines I just don't blame
the nor dimension for being like H we're
good we're good you stay out we do get a
cool moment where kamala's nor light and
bans her fist to punch Saleem and save
Bruno and then her arm just stretches to
clear the room there's a very important
moment where njma grabs kamala's Bengal
and a portal opens showing the train
with Karachi on it it is a steam engine
train something from the' 40s I am
thinking the clandestines Betrayed Aisha
by pushing her in front of that train
after AA refused to disclose that she
gave that Bengal to Sana Nakia realizes
Kamala is that NightLight hero she's
been been mad at and she completely
Savages Bruno Nakia will take care of me
no just go Kamala refuses to admit to
her family that she did pull the fire
alarm and ruined the wedding and then
her naughy Sana calls telling Kamala
that she and miva need to come to
Karachi ASAP did you see the train B you
have to come to Karachi this is a
breakdown of M Marvel episode 4 which
takes Kamala to Pakistan for even more
boys to fight over her you get yours
Kamala from hidden Realms to Ant-Man
mural and erdu let's break down this
episode frame by frame all the details
you missed cuz there is so much to
explain here unlike previous episodes
this opening previously on segment
switches to erdu as much of the visible
text this episode does including the
closing credits as this series
transitions from Jersey City to Karachi
Pakistan over the Marvel Fanfare the
music is Summer Nights by rinder
featuring wise child foreshadowing
sana's later description of the night
she was separated from Aisha at the
train station it was the middle of
partition and it was a hot summer night
a tragic summer night Cala revisits in
the episode's final scene the opening
shot shows outside of the plane window a
cloud looming over the city of Karachi
with the wing light shining through and
for a second it evokes the existential
threat facing this dimensional plane
revealed later this episode the veil of
no collapsing in the alternate realm of
light flooding this one it has been some
time since Kamala ruined amir's wedding
and she hasn't heard from her friend
Akia she squirrels through her text
quickly but they read I'm so sorry
please answer me I'll explain everything
hopefully you're all okay and no one is
hurt I wish things could go back to
normal and like they were before please
say something to anything I don't know
why I thought I could be a hero it's so
much harder than I thought I don't know
what else to say or how to fix this I'm
really sorry please just let me know
you're okay though I don't know why
Camala expected new text to come in
she's been on an international flight
and the plane isn't really low enough to
get a cell signal unless she's using the
inflight Wi-Fi but even then since it's
international flight wouldn't she have
to switch her SIM card I don't know she
might just be doing that thing where
she's reviewing a bunch of texts that
she sent right before the flight
departed and now as the flight is
landing she's waiting for a new signal
panicking waiting for what that response
will be because I always do this I'm
always wondering am I fired am I fired
am I fired does everyone hate me does
everyone hate me did a trailer drop midf
flight these are anxiety poison I like
how I has they to send people to start
to stand up to get stuff out of the
overhead sit
down sit down I mean this is the case on
any flight but especially international
flights just a very common and weird
thing for passengers to do Kamala
arrives at the Karachi Airport Blinded
By the Light of the excitement around
her we see a returning Champion cricket
team celebrating and then she is
showered with red flower pedals
recalling Her Fantasy of camran in
episode 2 and she's greeted by her
cousins and her Nani s they pass by a
mural of Muhammad Ali Jen the founder of
Pakistan and they pass under this sign
Karachi the City of Lights another hint
of the Hidden realm threatening This
Plane the nor Dimension nor course
minian light this is literally the City
of Lights about to become a city of even
more light now they used a number of
establishing shots from the city of
Karachi but all the exterior shots with
the actors were shot on Lots in Thailand
then mixed into the opening Miz Marvel
titles are a number of them written in
erdu and I like how one of these M
Marvel logos is scorched into a
delicious piece of naan they arrive at
saa's home where they meet the wonderful
dog of Magnum who needs to immediately
become best friends with lucky Camala
finds sana's study SL painting room
where on the walls are newspaper
clippings related to the partition one
mentions Lord mount Batton addressing
the Pakistan constituent assembly Lord
mount Batton was a royal Navy commander
and member of the British royal family
who oversaw the partition and was
assassinated by the IRA in 19 79 a
fascinating episode of the crown where
he's played by Charles Dance Tywin
Lannister you know the show The Crown
where we all have to like pretend we
care about the wings of the royal family
oh my horse doesn't like me meanwhile
what are we doing to imperialize the
world never mind that my cousin is
flirting with me it's just one of the
many reasons I like this show for
telling stories about you know everyone
else in the world one of son's art
pieces shows figures in Shadow walking
across a purple hued Cosmic backdrop
looking a lot like the nor realm that
Camala briefly dropped into when she
first clipped on that bangal in episode
one and we see a bird's eye view of in
this episode after all SAA does see
those same trained Visions these are
likely Visions in her dreams too Cala
and S chat about their background am
I a Jin of course at least that is what
my father told me how are you so casual
about this I don't see what the whole
fuss is about it's just genetics no a
bit of a pun there gentics Sona explains
that the term gen is really just a name
given to them and tells her again that
story about how a trail of stars saved
her on the night of the Partition by
reuniting her with her father at that
chaotic train station until a trail of
stars appeared and took me right back
into his arms on the train and I am
assuming that this trail of stars will
be revealed to either be Aisha maybe
using her nor projections to save her or
perhaps the carrier of the other Bengal
like a cre Warrior maybe a forbearer to
Captain Marvel or maybe one of the cre
created Inhumans like blackbolt or Maxim
I'm still holding on to hope that
Inhumans might come up in this show
Kamala says that she can't figure out
this puzzle and keeps breaking it even
more yet saana advises if you have lived
like I have lost what I
have you learn to find beauty in the
pieces interesting wisdom for this era
that we're now entered in the MCU that a
broken fractured Multiverse is more
beautiful than one that makes sense
Camala flashes back to the battle at the
wedding hall in episode 3 including this
one shot of autumn striking her F this
guy but notice how light flashes on him
so we are seeing him from kamala's point
of view as her nor light activated to
Shield her she has this Vision as the
portrait of Aisha rests beside her on
the pillow showing how she's really
sharing this dream with her
great-grandmother oh sorry I didn't
realize you were in here with someone
yeah her cousin is joking about her
sloth baby napping pillow but Camala was
with someone here Aisha Camala and the
rest have to eat on the patio because of
the boat club's no jeans policy or is it
a no Genie policy policy I'm sorry I
will leave I am so
sorry as they tour the city Camala wears
her New Jersey Avenger conon shirt that
she got at the convention back at
episode 1 her cousin says on is this not
exotic enough for the ABCDs
Instagram you know American Born
confused D I know what it means yes this
is a term used by South Asian people to
refer to second and third generation
Americans at their same ethnicity might
also remind you of the slang ABC or
American Born Chinese which showed up in
Crazy Rich Asia SS in one of the texts
and might also be the reference in the
ABC Chinese restaurant in this episode
but I feel like none of this is for me
to discuss I am sorry I love you all I'm
just trying to learn and I'll shut up
now at the Polaroid stand there is a QR
code one of these of course appears in
every episode and this week when you
scan it it takes you to M Marvel number
12 from 2015 you can read this comic for
free here this is when Camala travels to
Karachi and runs into the red dagger and
I love the joke here this is a Polaroid
Stand The Meta joke is for us to
literally take a picture with our phones
of this stand Kamala visits a train
station and checks out a historic
section that's under renovation and
there's a mural of Ant-Man resizing from
small to large and he's speaking a word
bubble in eru which translates to as
powerful as an ant and then there is a
text box you can start small and still
be Larger than Life Karachi Avengers
series part 4 telling us that this is
part of a series I love it the artist is
Sarah Hussein after Adrian Alona Adrian
Alona was the artist of the G Willer
Wilson Miz Marvel series and his name
also appeared as a school founder back
in episode 1 and we got to point out
that this is the latest of many Ant-Man
references on this series which might
just be because Ant-Man is a low stakes
comedic Avenger that Cala in the show
references more than the others to
balance out all the nods to Captain
Marvel and Iron Man also he is one of
the more public facing Avengers since it
was his podcast that she listened to to
learn about what happened in in game
also Hawkeye did have a weird amount of
Ant-Man nods that didn't really amount
to anything but it is just a reminder
that people on the street level of the
MCU are all about Ant-Man in pimp Tech
and I really hope that we do see a
version of kamala's powers where she can
truly resize the way Ant-Man can she's
then attacked by the red Badger Kareem
also from this run of the Comics
vigilante from Karachi who actually ends
up moving to Jersey City he asks her do
all Mas can have superpowers well how do
you know I'm not Canadian yeah met a
joke here Iman valani is Canadian might
be why she's so dang likable Kamala uses
her imig nor fist to punch Kareem and he
releases a series of nor darts that if
you look closely actually go into
ant-man's legs on that mural Cala
catches a dagger in her hand the way
Bucky can catch knives but she's
definitely not as good at throwing
[Music]
it they end up referenc seeing Ninja
Turtles in danky can and they fight to a
draw come with me if you want to live
what just kidding I've always wanted to
say that yes the famous line from the
Terminator but I like how Kamala doesn't
get the reference why because Terminator
a movie for dance just G it's a movie
for everyone everyone should watch it
really just T2 Judgment Day no joke top
five movie for me I've love that movie
and I'm not even a dad but I want to be
one as they enter The Hideout Cala asks
red
daggers what you a Pakistani boy band
another boy band reference in the MCU
The Avengers broke up we toast like a
band like like the Beatles The Avengers
yeah that's great thank you what is that
wait you don't have the Avengers is that
a band are you the band fantastic for
didn't you guys chart in the 60s she
meets wed played by the amazing actor
Faron octar who actually starred in the
movie the sky is pink whose song played
in the credits of last episode he
explains here the clandestines are not
like the Jin you've heard about stories
on religious texts I mean if Thor landed
in the Himalayan Mountains he too would
have been called a Jin yes will is
alluding to the concept that Thor and
other asgardians only have their Norse
identities because of where on Earth
they arrived in reality Thor is an
extraterrestrial and the clandestines
are interdimensional it's just the human
societies who call them Jinn Jin really
come from pre-islamic folklore far
predating the hundred years that the
clandestines have been here now big
announcement the god butcher World Tour
is here and epic hero shop has the merch
for it and what's more epic than the
necros swur skewering Thor's head done
up in an 80s heavy metal style nothing
none more Epic on the back of it's got
tour stops that include Realms Gore
visited in the comics and places he
might hit in the movie get it on a
t-shirt or a poster or both so you can
match your wall and if you're worried
about your head feeling left out get
Thor's strongest Avengers hat while
supplies last grab these designs and
mark your calendars because on July 7th
we are dropping a new latest Obsession
and of course don't forget about the Miz
Marvel collection they got shoes and
stickers notebooks and bomber jackets
shop these designs and more at epicer
shop.com while lead continues the
clandestines and Aisha are from another
[Music]
realm this map shows you how are two
worlds coexist whoo a lot to unpack here
so notice how W twists a knob to show
the superimposition of another realm map
hovering over our world map if you were
to twist that knob a bit more who knows
we might see a different realm map now
these lines do not adhere to any
geography topography or tectonic
features of our planet or aligned to
really any place of interest in the MCU
like wakanda or new Asgard and that is a
counting for if you were to align from
while Le's vantage point but he uses the
term realm which is different from how
Universe has been used in the MCU so to
be clear here Universe refers to
parallel realities within a Multiverse
Each of which are doppelgangers of our
world with variants of ourselves living
in it the 616 Universe the 838 Universe
the variants we saw in what if the
alternate Manhattans that strange in
America crash through because notied
even the honeycomb world the tube world
the bone world were still alternate
Urban Manhattans just made of different
things so set that aside while we
explain what real are Realms refer to
surrealist ethereal buffer zones between
universes where unknown beings live so
you got the nor Dimension talo from
shuni and the Realms Beyond where the
dweller in darkness originated the dark
dimension the quantum realm The
ancestral plane the duat underworld
Valhalla the Gap Junction the mirror
Dimension the astrop plane the shadow
realm from Thor love and thunder
thanos's Soul realm all of these seem to
be accessed either via death or through
physical waypoints that are hidden in
our reality and a lot of the Realms I
just mentioned definitely have spiritual
connotations and they seem to be
constant to all of the universes that I
mentioned in the Multiverse like there
might be only one Quantum realm that is
shared by all these universes I think
like I'm mostly getting that from Agents
of Shield in which they use the quantum
realm to bridge different timelines but
this also seemed to be the case in
Multiverse of Madness where Clea took
strange to the dark dimension to fix an
incursion between universes suggesting
that the dark dimension is a kind of
neutral zone where they could look at
two distinct universes independent of
any one of them then we see another
device showing the nor Dimension there
are many dimensions around us that we
cannot see this is just one of them what
is this Aisha's home it's connected to
our world but hidden behind the veil of
n that separates our world from this yes
more to unpack the veil of nor is this
realm's Waypoint like the waterfall that
separated Earth from talo and shuni and
the dragon scale gate that separated
tallo from the Realms Beyond where the
soul sucker comes from so this nor realm
isn't implied to exist on a dimensional
plane on top of our realm similar to how
the mirror Dimension and the astral
plane and the shadow realm exist all
around us just unseen this might be why
beings like the jackals and moonnight
and gargos were initially invisible the
nor Realms surrealist columns Tower high
above the highrises of Karachi and it
glows the same color of kamala's nor
light this is definitely the realm that
she briefly fell into back in episode 1
also look closely on the far end of the
nor realm is a tree which seems very
important when tchala The ancestral
plane he saw his Panther Spirit
ancestors in a tree to me this indicates
that the nor Dimension also has a
spiritual Essence to it also I like how
this realm assembles in this device via
gray Sands or grains reminding us of the
granular vibranium that the wakandans
use to depict their Origins but then
while leading Kareem warn new is the
energy source of that realm The Veil The
clandestines even your powers are made
of it if the clandestines use the bangle
to tear down the veil they'll unleash
their world on to us until there's
nothing left of it yeah this sounds a
lot like the incursions we heard about
in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
manness when one Universe collides with
another Universe an incursion occurs
when the boundary between two universes
erodes and they
Collide destroying one or both entirely
so I don't know I may be wrong about
there being a difference between
universe and realm and the way Marvel
Studios defines these terms and maybe
this realm incursion is meant to be the
same thing as a universe incursion but I
don't know for now I think universes and
Realms are different enough to assume
that they are different categories of
dimensional terrains and both are just
affected by the same crisis so if we
imagine each Universe to be its own
house in a row of cookie cutter model
homes in a Suburban Street Realms would
be the yards the driveways the sidewalks
the streets the ponds the aquafers the
gas lines the avocado trees the dog
houses between all these houses and so
for two houses to collide with each
other there must be some kind of flood
or earthquake that also causes the yards
the gas lines the avocado trees to smash
into those houses first those trees and
Turf and water all amounting to what a
realm is a buffer zone in between the
houses and we may have already seen some
realm incursions existing in the MCU
that could explain what these
Supernatural things are things like the
invisible jackals things like vampires
all these Supernatural entities actually
coming from Realms not other universes
and this earthquake in this extended
metaphor could be a series of smaller
trimmers caused by several different
disruptors like Sylvia and Loki and
Peter Parker Doctor Strange Wanda
maximoff all of them leading to one big
earthquake causing it all to collide
Realms and universes I know I could be
dead wrong about all that that's just
where my head is at right now and In
This Moment wed eyes is the bangal I
haven't seen that before in all the
years and everything I've heard about
that bangal there was no mention of an
inscription it says what you seek is
seeking you so since wed can read this
and the myths never mentioned an
inscription I think this was added later
by Aisha a message that the trail of
stars being sought by sauna and now by
Kamala is some kind of chain of
extraterrestrials cre or Inhumans
seeking them I assuming the ones seeking
them are the same entities being
summoned by the beacon in the 10 rings
and this inscription is a warning then
we visit the dodc supermax prison which
is the same facility we see in the
She-Hulk trailer meaning the Abomination
me blansky is also being kept in this
place further confirmation that the
authorities facing Kamala in this series
is the same agency Jen Walter will deal
with we speculated this could be the
cube the super villain containment
prison in the Nevada desert originally a
shield black site designed for gamma
radiated inmates later becoming the home
base of the Thunderbolts notice how this
structures angular architecture does
look like a deconstructed or exploded
Cube The clandestines Break Free ciman
getting hit with the blast of one of the
dodc Sonic cannons the same ones made
from the Stark Tech shrunken down
versions of his Hulk repulser that he
installed on War Machine najma's weapon
looks like a medu used in the Tamil
martial arts it's made of deer horns but
in this case it looks like it's made of
something different because we see it
melting a lock so apparently her weapon
at least can super heat back in Pakistan
Sana tells Kamala the confusion between
her Pakistani and Indian Roots there is
a border marked with blood and pain yeah
it's my favorite detail this episode
when it comes to thematic connection
between sana's border and the border of
the veil of no saana explains how all
political borders are a bit arbitrary
and leave us divided this episode
explains how the political map we
thought we knew of this planet is
actually pretty irrelevant when you
superimpose the maps of other realms
over this one Cala joins Kareem's
friends around a bonfire as this guy
sings an erdu cover of Dei by chb khed
meanwhile son Mana reconnect over going
through milk toffe boxes remember saana
sent Camala the Bengal in one of these
boxes in episode one and after Sana and
manba are finally honest with each
other's episode the trauma begins to
heal as the next generation of women
Bond over eating these milk tofes I just
love the visual storytelling of this
prop here W gives Kamala some fabric to
wear showing how she is piecing together
her own costume but the clan Destin's
attack leading to a Chase in the streets
of Karachi now they referenced
Terminator earlier I just can't help but
see a parallel in the good guys on the
small Rick Shaw versus the clandestines
pursuing on the larger truck and the
Terminator John Connor and T2 on the
motorcycle fleeing the T1000 on the semi
Cala spots a family of four way insanely
trying to pile on a motorcycle the baby
should not be on that Kamala forms a nor
ramp that rolls the truck and Kamala
ends up back behind the wheel a call
back to her driving test in episode one
and just like then she floors it in
reverse initially wed kills Saleem and
then n stabs wed and kareim kills Adam
and njma stabs the Bengal sending Kamala
through this Rift now these tears in the
fabric of reality look a lot like the
slices that Clea made in the Multiverse
of mtis post credit scene when she tore
an opening back to the dark dimension
which makes me think that Kamala is not
going back in time here she's really
going into the nor Dimension the light
Dimension versus the dark dimension and
this is really a memory that she's going
into of course she finds herself back on
that hot summer night at the train
station that Sana referred to when the
families were forced to separate during
the partition it is heart breaking to
end this episode here but I'm not sure
if Kamala is truly being transported
back in time like you could totally read
this as Kamala is going to be the one to
create the trail of stars she's going to
save her own grandmother it's going to
be self-fulfilling time Loop Harry
Potter saving himself another version of
hold the door from Game of Thrones I
mean I don't know that might be the case
I'm just leaning towards this being
memory contained within the Bengal
because as Kamala walks around no one
really looks at her or reacts to her
there's just one guy who kind of steps
around her when she turns to climb the
train car and Creek is known for being
intertwined with memor from project
toiti and Agents of Shield warping
certain aspects of coulson's memory to
Carol Danver having implanted memories
causing her to see Scrolls as the enemy
so I think Kamala is on a similar
journey of self-discovery that Carol was
on similarly witnessing this memory but
from the point of view of her
grandmother or her great-grandmother she
may be walking one of their shoes in
this moment Kamala does see a woman with
her daughter but this woman is credited
as a different actress than the actress
who plays Aisha also remember Aisha was
separated from SAA In This Moment SAA
would have been with her dad and then
separated from her dad as well and then
the trail of stars brought her back back
to her dad I assume next episode we will
see exactly what that trail of stars was
whatever Cosmic source is seeking the
Bengal again could be the cre or their
Teran experiments the Inhumans folks
like blackbolt or Maximus for now at
least folks the Inhumans are still on
the table and the final shot does show
Cala being enveloped in Steam from the
steam engine as Haze surrounds the
masses a visual nitogen Mist we may have
missed the mist and again something I
love about the closing credits the
locals have been all swapped from Jersey
City to karach on the green Traffic
Light from Brad wibom instead of
kamala's Bolt logo on the light it is
the Pakistani flag another thing they
swapped out the art of Kamala sitting on
the swing now hangs from the crescent
and the star of the Pakistani flag what
was the title of this episode seeing red
and like Doctor Strange Kamala was
forced to go on red in this case go on
that smoke show K this is a breakdown of
M Marvel episode 5 which further breaks
ccu's already broken time travel logic
but does so in the most beautiful way
while doing to the clandestines what
would happen to me if I ever tried to
leave this blue
dungeon I am going to explain exactly
what happened this episode some
interesting Easter eggs that you might
have missed into some really cool visual
details this episode opens with a song
called toera Chand by sah and xiam from
the 1949 Bollywood film dagi which
itself was an adaptation of the 1939
film weing Heights the story of a tragic
Romance of lovers Kathy and heathcliffe
who were forced apart by circumstance
Kathy first appears as a ghost before
her story is told via flashback just as
this episode flashback on characters
thought to be ghostly Jin catching up to
their tragic parting of ways actually
the song to maran's words translate to
you are my moon I am your moon light
which if you think about it is a
variation on what you seek is seeking
you Cala herself being the light that
she seeks in fact really the phrase what
you seek is seeking you is a way to
describe how all of us are on
predestined paths that loved ones and
things that you seek out are also on a
destined path to find their way to you
the Marvel Studios title imagery
transitions to a sepat toned grainy film
stock that skips in a 4x3 letter box
aspect ratio as this becomes a 1940s
newsreel explaining the partition with
the newly appointed Indian Prime
Minister jawahar ALU and we see
Pakistan's political founder Muhammad
Ali Jin a mural of whom appeared in
Karachi last episode we see a map
showing India and Pakistan dividing with
territory to the rest of India
demarcated for Pakistan but also a
section to the east this would go on to
become Bangladesh but initially at the
start of the partition Bengal's assembly
voted to be part of Pakistan that is
until 1971 when war broke out and
Bangladesh secured its independence as a
separate country from Pakistan we also
see Mahatma Gandhi the Indian Freedom
Fighter arguably most influential in
India's independence from British rule
who was assassinated a year after this
in 1948 this episode then jumps back to
1942 which was really the year Gandhi
first openly formally began pushing for
the British to just completely leave
India Aisha fle a British soldier after
leaving the ruins of where they found
the Bengal that was marked with the 10
Rings logo back in episode 3 weer cut
from her bare feet to his boots and then
she flings an ornate dagger at him
presumably this is her clandestine
weapon as they all can summon weapons
but it aligns Aisha more with the red
dagger Society last episode The Miz
Marvel titles flickered between English
and erdu now we only have one English
one shown on a torn British flag but the
rest are in various languages there's
Urdu Hindi Gujarati Punjabi Bengali
Tamil and Telugu actually last week
there was one in the colors of the 1992
Pakistan cricket national team so it's
just kind of fun to go through these one
by one so let's do it after the Union
Jack there's one in erdu showing the
shadows of Muslim refugees on a wall
with bullet holes in it then one in
Hindi showing a field of flowers then
another one in erdu showing the mural of
the red daggers and you see there is one
male and one female then there's another
one in erdu showing a photograph of
refugees then another in Hindi on a blue
train car marked with NWR India's
Northwestern State Railway hinting at
the trains that they have to take out of
India then in asames or Bengali in Smoke
by the train tracks then one in Hindi
over a map showing the border between
India and Pakistan then another in
asamer Bengali then an interesting one a
cracked Border in concrete on one side
erdu on the Lower Side Hindi a literal
partition between erdu and Hindi
matching the border between Pakistan and
India then one into lugu actually in a
stylish font of Canada over a field of
roses like Hassan's Rose Garden
overlooking a city in the midst maybe a
hint at the nor Dimension then one in
Punjabi stamped on a resettlement card
for the KH family one man one woman one
infant registration office 4291 index
number 12 cards like these were assigned
to migrant Muslim families then one in
garati on a tapestry then another in
Punjabi over a parody of the Vintage
Universal Pictures logo reading Marvel
Studios presents and a sloth baby
production that of course is kamala's
YouTube channel then one in taml over a
depiction of refugees then another inua
purple text on a cosmic background and
then one final one in erdu green over
roses in Hassan's Village a few kids are
playing Cricket women purchase some
bracelets and Hassan stirs up the crowd
citing Mahatma Gandhi to resist being
forced off their land but British
soldiers break up the crowd Aisha naps
in Hassan's rose garden roses being very
important to the language and culture
and the general lore of the country of
Pakistan inside Hassan says you know
when I saw you out there it reminded me
of my favorite
poem when the soul lies down in that
grass the world is too full to talk
about would you seek seeking you yes
he's quoting roomi a 13th century
Persian poet a Sufi Mystic and a major
influence on the entire Muslim World
Aisha is smitten and reveals her name my
name is Aisha Aisha she who
lives a beautiful man yes she who lives
ironically dies this episode some time
passes and Aisha givs Assan with a new
Walking Stick as she Sports one of the
Roses in her hair looking a lot like s's
painting of her that we saw last episode
they both rest their hands on her baby
bump as the bangal is framed right
beside it symbolizing how this bangal
will pass down through the women of this
lineage Aisha sings and erdu laabi and
as the division between the Muslims and
the Hindus grow wider njma finds Aisha
and gives her until sundown to retrieve
the bangal so that they can go back to
their home Dimension so Aisha gets the
family to flee to the train station but
Hassan confronts her who's that woman
you were talking to last
night yeah noce the music mixes in that
menacing sting that's always been used
to introduce the threat of
NAA I've been waiting a very long time
to meet you Aisha shows in the bangle
and writing appears on the Cuffs outer
bands this is the inscription that she
she added that W noticed later quoting
Hassan's recitation of room's poem now
since the clandestine can transfigure
their token weapons this tells us that
she has turned to the protective Bengal
as her token unfortunately najma still
has her weapon and Aisha without any
protection gets stabbed in the stomach
as najma walks off Aisha warns her it
won't work huh so what does Aisha know
about the death trap of traveling
through the veil of no that NAA does not
or at least does not want to believe
Aisha may be more privy to the terms of
their banishment and or more peace with
her Exile Aisha's life drains from her
you seek seek you and the bengle glows
as doe Aisha's eyes and this either
coincides with or causally triggers
kamala's arrival through the rift in
time opened up by the bangle for the
present day last episode yes this
episode confirms that Camala actually
traveled back in time and it was she who
cast the trail of stars that saved her
own grandmother now this type of time
travel is referred to as a closed loop
or predestination where in unexplained
anomalies from the past are later
revealed to be the effect of present
characters looping back to the past
events to set the timeline the way it
has always been it's actually one of the
more common tropes in time travel
fiction you may know it from prisoner of
asab ban where a mysterious Patronus
that saves Harry Potter was actually
cast by himself looping back to the past
or from Terminator where the human
resistance leader John Connor was
conceived by the same protector who went
back in time to save his mother or
Christopher Nolan's Interstellar or
tenant where bizarre phenomena happened
early on in the movie and are later
revealed to be the same Heroes looping
back on themselves filmmakers will often
default to this because these twists do
pack some narrative catharsis suggesting
that the chaos of the world is actually
part of a divine plan but it also
implies characters have no free will
since for their lives to even exist they
must make the choice of time travel that
choice has really been made for them now
you may feel this violates the mcu's
time travel logic from Avengers endgame
which suggested traveling back in time
doesn't cause you to live within the
past as it was but rather form a new
Branch timeline a separate reality
however endg game's Own Ending
contradicts that logic with the
confusing arrival of old Steve Rogers
the screenwriters claim old cap lived in
the background of the MCU as we've known
it which violates their own Branch
timeline logic meanwhile the directors
maintain old cap must have traveled back
to this timeline from a different
reality ultimately folks The Narrative
priority with that final scene was not
logic it was really emotional catharsis
but then we got Loki which gave us a lot
of new rules of how time travel works in
the MCU but that series ended did by
suggesting that all the events of the
MCU were part of he who remains
predestined script the sacred timeline
and that includes even the eventuality
that the sacred timeline would unravel
into Infinite branches the Gambit he
remains posed to Loki and Sylvie was
really a false Choice he knew that
Sylvie would stab him and that the
timeline would rupture into a Multiverse
he wanted that to happen that was part
of his plan now he who remains monologue
and Loki's finale do remain up for
interpretation but one conclusion we can
all agree on is that Marvel Studios sees
themselves as Master Clock makers and
their universe as a predestined road map
a timeline engineered in Universe by
manipulators like Kang in specific ways
that we're about to learn a lot more
about so this seeming accident of Kamala
connecting with her great grandmother
through these Bangles through time was
pre-ordained and designed by someone and
if you look closely at those branching
timelines around the Citadel in the Loki
finale many of them do intersect with
each other and bend backwards upon
themselves each intersection ction may
represent an incursion Multiverse of
manness showed us what an incursion
looks like when universes Collide W
shows us what an incursion looks like
when Realms Collide and now we are
seeing what an incursion looks like when
timelines Collide now Aisha does say
here Banger worked s it brought you back
to me I'm not son of yeah see Aisha did
not think she was opening a rift in time
to summon her great granddaughter from
the future she just wanted the Bengal to
save her daughter sauna so from that I
think we conclude it was not najma St
having the bangal in the present that
opened the rift and it wasn't Aisha's
sort of prayer that opened the rift from
the past according to Loki causality is
incidental no matter what these points
in the timeline were going to intersect
and history here just Justified itself
with the stimuli to trigger it
internally in this instance it was a
piece of cre Tech or some other alien
Tech mixed with clandestine nor magic to
tear this Rift into reality the walls of
which have already been weakening from
all these things that have been
happening in the MCU theoretically this
origin could have been scripted out out
by Kang or one of the kangs to produce a
clandestine descendant armed with cre
Tech to join the pantheon of Marvel
heroes in his eventual master plan to
Stage a secret Wars event or maybe by
some other Kang to produce a friend for
Kang's alterate itself of Nathaniel
Richard's iron lad in a Young Avengers
lineup there's a lot of ways we can read
this but hey welcome to phase four folks
time travel none of this makes sense so
yes Kamala creates a nor platform to
create a path for SAA but then she gets
knocked by someone and the platform
dissipates but stays in this star form
that is controlled by Sana herself
guiding herself back to Hassan she was
able to do this because she had some nor
magic in her blood and had the bangal so
in a sense one bangal was reunited with
another bangal just the same one through
time however we got to remember there is
another bangle one for the right hand
that exists somewhere hidden in this
world I'm assuming among the collection
of Dane Whitman's Uncle Nathan so Kamala
returns to the present where the veil of
no Rift has opened it glows from Golden
to teal color def fuchsia and it widens
and widens as Faria reaches into it she
turns into a statue of what this
episode's audio description refers to as
quote black crystalline Rock which then
crumbles to reveal her skeleton and yes
this transformation does resemble the
way penesis is shown in Agents of Shield
teragen Mist forms a rocky cocoon around
a person and then they emerge from that
cocoon as an inhuman with powers in the
clandestine case clearly not but a
similar aesthetic is at least worth
noting maybe terog Genesis will be
revealed in the series as a worthiness
judgment in the nor realm like what we
saw in the datat realm in moonnight with
the scales of Anubis like in this case
as you pass through the veil if your
heart is impure you emerge from that
cocoon dead but if your heart is pure
like maybe if Aisha or Kamala were to
try to pass through this Veil they'd
emerge from that cocoon transformed or I
don't know maybe they just wanted to
show how the veil of no's energy
differential melts you into bones like
the wrath of God in Indiana Jones but
Disney made them put up this goofy
vanity curtain to spare viewers from the
gorier details so then najima offers
herself to the veil portal and suddenly
feeling bad for for leaving camaran
behind utters his name and transfers her
nor light through the veil killing
herself but the way Aisha's nor light
summoned her descendant through time or
maybe it was just a random coincidence
because of Kang yeah yeah yeah I know we
talked about that najma's nor light
redirects to Camron giving him the same
imig nor light that Kamala has except
more teal colored and apparently able to
be controlled without the use of a
bangle so in the comics Camron is an
inhuman the way Kamala is he's just hit
with the same teren Mist that Kamala is
exposed to and it gives him different
powers than stretchy limbs he has blue
colored inner
bioluminescence look folks I am just
doing my best to explain what the hell
happened here the logic of the clanes on
the show is largely unexplained I'm not
a writer on the show this is all super
inconsistent with G Willer Wilson's
Comics so uh light is Magic and can be
transferred among descendants of
extradimensional beings Amplified by
alien Tech that's connected to the 10
rings I guess Marvel Studios is just
teragen phobic and they will throw
literally anything from Marvel lur
against the wall hoping YouTube will
make sense of it for them which uh yeah
yeah you got us Hook Line and Sinker but
I always do love the use of of light and
color on this show and I love how the
alleyway and lighting that accompanied
Camron for pretty much the rest of this
episode are that same blue hue that his
inhuman form is in the comics but Camala
proves that her trip to the Past was not
just a dream or a vision she brought
back with her a physical item the way
Hawkeye brought back a baseball glove to
the present as proof here the photograph
actually parallels Pixar's Coco the
wayward child meeting their ancestor and
returning with a family photo to heal
the generational divide within their
living relatives Kareem tells Kamala
although the US government may or may
not have several warrants for my arrest
US Government this guy's a Pakistani
citizen it just sounds like the red
dagger's vigilantism has gotten the
attention of US Agencies like the dodc
and may set up Kareem to return in
titles like the Thunderbolts yeah yeah
it'll be fine he could be another one of
B's recruits where I'm sure Kareem will
just have to deal with quite a few
racist microaggressions from John Walker
but Kareem gives Kamala his Red Scarf
remember last episode wed gave Kamala
this blue vest saana gave her the Bengal
Bruno gave her the mask and I guess she
provided her own red shoes that the
mosque Thief let her keep really we're
seeing all the components of her final
form contributed to her by different
influences within her community and now
the final piece of it Mana finds her
golden necklace that previously showed
kamala's name in erdu but now bent to
form her swishy bolt logo I assume next
episode manba will complete the Arc of
the unused Hulk outfit and create
kamala's final superhero look and Cala
will actually be a good daughter and
wear it in the Scrapbook that they look
at are some old photos of manba and some
ticket stubs from concerts she went to
one reading Bruce presumably for Bruce
Springsteen whom Sonic calls Bruce
Springfield before maniva corrects her
to bonjovi and then there's a blue
ticket stub the blue ticket stub was for
a show at the Oakland Coliseum telling
us that monba spent some time in the Bay
Area Cala says why have I never heard of
this which is what Mona asked earlier
about the find my phone feature then why
am I only just hearing about this yes
the mother and daughter are more alike
than they realize Camron finds Bruno in
the alley this interaction witnessed by
a closed circuit security camera
presumably the dodc was using the
government facial recognition software
we know Shield uses to track Loki in the
2012 Avengers that must be how they
tracked kamran to this location Camron
doesn't really get Bruno's argon science
joke poster this is exactly the kind of
nerd humor that Peter Parker wears on
his shirts actor Matt Lin actually
auditioned to play the MCU Peter Parker
before the role went Tom Holland like
every scene I watch this guy and I'm
like yeah he could have been a pretty
great Peter Parker tomaron also doesn't
know who the inventor Nicola Tesla is he
assumes it's just a posted to for Tesla
cars but then one of the dodc drones
retrofitted from the Stark drones from
Far From Home appear outside the window
and camon uses his nor to swat it away
blasting out the window glass but
Bruno's chachkies are still standing the
Drone retaliates by completely leveling
the circle Q shop between this and
delmar's Deli and queens that we saw in
Spider-Man homecoming the bers of the
New York area are under attack and we
must protect them at all cost so now
with the Bland Destin's toast in the
veil of nor closed it seems like the
final Conflict of the finale will be
with agent diver in the dodc and sure
maybe a trigger happy racial profiling
government agency will be enough
especially with this agency returning
shulk and maybe secret Invasion but
remember it is still a mystery where the
Bengal came from and how it is connected
with the 10 rings so we may learn more
about deeper and clear's connections to
a broader conflict with the cre ahead of
the Marvels and of course I think harol
danverse owes us just a little Cameo
this is a breakdown of Miz Marvel
episode 6 the finale which establishes
the MCU Kamala con is a
mutant with Kevin feige erasing in
humans faster than wanted did the mouth
of their
King from major Marvel proclamations to
twisty post credit H to this episode's
astute attention to detail with the MCU
timeline logic I am going to to break
down everything you missed this episode
and explain it all without a home alone
chalk board the episode opens back in
Jersey City agent dver says this is what
happens when the wrong people get powers
the wrong people kids agent very another
microaggression from dver but in this
case toward you kids having powers is a
bit of a new trend in the MCU these days
a young adventur team up is imminent
also all this talk of government
Crackdown on superheroes does remind us
a lot of a you know mutant registration
and that too is the era we are now in
Bruno helps comron on the subway so
we're going to transfer at the next stop
and head Upstate okay Upstate from New
York you know what else is Upstate New
York uh Westchester a pretty good place
for a mutant to run away to now we don't
know yet if Camron is a mutant as well
if he can harness his norite the same
way Kamala can maybe over the opening
credits is a 2018 Track by artist janubi
kro called Captain space it's title a
nod to Captain Marvel who swaps places
with Kamala in the post credit scene
likely connected to this Captain's link
to the space Stone and cre Tech like the
Nega ban which is what it looks like the
Bengals are we see the Statue of Liberty
inexplicably green once more even though
Spider-Man no way home showed how it was
being restored to its Brown copper color
and no way home takes place before Miz
Marvel this episode was deliberate about
setting itself in 2025 so I don't know
what's going on here but when I saw the
Statue of Liberty in the no way home
trailer remember I was like X-Men 2000
reference mutants are coming to form so
I don't know I choose to interpret this
as M Marvel showing me the Statue of
Liberty in a title that does actually
end with the proclamation of mutants in
the MCU as a nod to the famous climax of
that 2000 film a symbol of arrival to a
new world both the immigrants of the KH
family and we could paraphrase that poem
as give me your tired your poor your HUD
old mutants Longing To Breathe free
Camala reveals her powers to her family
but they all already know a little
detail from the G Willa Wilson's Comics
Taisha asks are your powers Limitless or
do you have to recharge oh yeah Cala
doesn't get to answer but this could be
a nod to how in the DC Comics Green
Lantern has to recharge The Miz Marvel
titles take us back to Jersey City we
see police tape then a blueprint then
kamala's handdrawn puppets from her
video in episode 1 then imprinted on her
High School hoodie established 2014
referring to Kamala con solo series
published in 2014 initially then in neon
over the circle Q store before it
exploded then on the school bus then on
an arm cast cuz you know Bruno's arm is
in a cast right now and then on a
digitized screen of an old game boy or
maybe a TI 83 calculator then on a
Jersey City police squad car then on a
train station destination board karach
is actually listed right above it then
the neon outlines from kamala's fantasy
with Camron back in episode 2 they're
surrounded here by halal food carts
riding a hot dog past a ferris wheel
with hamburgers on it then written a
Street Paint then painted on that
graffiti wall among her and Bruno's
cosplay pitches back from episode 1 I
like how all the Avengers by the way
depicted there are ones adjacent of his
Marvel on the phase four lineup
including doctor strange Black Panther
and Captain Marvel and then lastly her
pure nor form signaling the completion
of kamala's evolution on this show
manima gives Camala her own new suit in
a milk toppies box this is what SA
mailed the bangle to her in and we
learned in episode four Sonic kept these
boxes around her home in Karachi and the
women of this family bonded over eating
these MBA began this season stitching
Kamala an Avenger costume that Cala did
not want but now Mana makes one unique
for Cala that she needs using elements
from kamala's Journey the embroidery if
you notice takes the form of
interlocking blue cubes evoking the
Tesseract the cosmic Tech that gave
Carol daners her powers Camala lily pads
across her Nord dis set to chai's light
switch the lyric being I want to see the
light with no light switch as Camala
learns this episode that her ability to
manifest her light doesn't necessarily
need the switch of her bangal the bangal
just kind of unlocked it now J the Euro
King returns a QR code appears in his
truck if you scan it this week it's been
updated to issue number 19 of G Willa
Wilson's Miss Marvel last days Arc which
ends with Bruno confessing his love for
Kamala but Cala telling him she doesn't
have room in her heart for a thing with
him right now this episode ends with
Bruno leaving a letter for Cala and we
have no idea what it said or if she even
read it also my favorite Dr this episode
n Sha's a sanitation grade is actually
dated March 14th 2025 attention to
detail proving this show is actually
trying to take seriously the MCU
timeline as this show would be set in
Spring 2025 after Hawkeye was in
Christmas 2024 in the mosque notice how
someone put their Fancy Shoes on the
highest cubby hole on that wall probably
to keep that short little shoe thet from
snatching them also on top of the
shelving unit some boxes block the
hidden door that we see later this is
where Nakia and the Sheik and the mosque
bro hide the two of them but dver
returns to the mosque in still refuses
to take her shoes off while walking out
on that prayer floor so rude no cookies
for dver Nikia tries to block dver um
it's holy whoa one of the AG is totally
dish shoulder check dver she seems
pretty isolated among her fellow dodc
investigators the dodc ain't all bad the
she gives Bruno and Camron the disguises
of Paul caps Haram and Halal the words
for forbidden and permissible this is
keeping up with the running MCU gag of
using mere ball caps as disguises
starting in Captain America Winter
Soldier and then mocked an Ant-Man the
WASP relax no one's going to recognize
us what because of hats and sunglasses
it's not a disguise Hank we look like
ourselves at a baseball game and in
Captain Marvel does uh announcing your
identity on clothing help with the
covert part of your job Camron nor
spasms yeah a little detail I like how
kamala's noore lights up on her hands
instinctively as she covers her ears and
has comeon screams we can hear nma's
voice calling out to him this would
suggest that nashma might not be fully
dead that either her soul lives on as
this no maybe when her Earthbound
corporeal body eroded into a skeleton
her actual Consciousness and her soul
transferred to the nor Dimension where
it now resides and is continuing to
puppet Camron to try to carry out her
evil plot to merge the nor Dimension
into this one when Kamala calls Kim he
is examining his map that W uses to show
the outline of the nor realm now the
magnifying lens is fixed on the border
between India and Pakistan like Kore
might be seen if the recent Veil
incident might have changed the border
between Realms and we find out that the
red daggers just have random boatsmen at
the New Jersey Harbor ready to go at
notice whenever and secret easy to
navigate underground tunnels to get
there throughout the school the posters
include if you see trash throw it away
and then stones of diversity build a
path to peace and then a comic book club
nice and then another one for Dustin
Barry for president a n to the set crew
member Dustin Barry on the show n Kia
joins them along with Zoe Zimmer what
are you doing here the theater has good
lighting it's where I film my Tik toks
remember in episode 2 Camala and Bruno
tested out her powers backstage at the
theater which might be how Zoe figured
out Camala was her hero their plan
involves him swiping hoodies from
lockers and a skeleton from a science
lab notice how Bruno Just Goofs around
in the background dancing with one Bruno
mistress death phas 4 hookup confirmed
and these chemicals the chalkboard
actually lists hydrogen peroxide dry
yeast warm water and liquid dis show
which actually are the ingredients for
that elephant to P foone that you see in
YouTube videos the dod soldiers arm
their sonic
cannons now remember these are Stark
Tech the repulsors he designed for the
Army to use on Hulk in the 2008 film and
then later installed in war machines
armor in Civil War and in the drones in
far from home actually since a dodc now
owns those drones they may have reverse
engineered those repulsors from the
drones themselves and here notice how
they charge by using the same charge
sound effect that Iron Man's technology
uses
Nakia and Zoe load some sockt balls
together I think Kamal should be able to
tell the world when she's
ready yeah this is a little notd to
Zoe's situation in the comics Zoe later
reveals a major crush on Nika Zoe
herself is definitely waiting to tell
the world when she is ready the dodc
agents bust in to find Bruno's AI Amazon
Alexa knockof zuu which plays KOCO
Corina from the 1966 erdu film Arman
sung by Ahmed rushi it's considered the
first real pop song of Pakistan the fact
that they cut it off by blasting zuu is
Criminal Zoe goes live on Tik Tok where
the comments include hang on help is
coming # help zo everyone in Jersey City
get to CHS Avengers go to Cole's High zo
needs you on the way zo # popcorn
popcorn backup coming zo squad on i78 WE
helping our girl stop commenting go to
CHS now and then popcorn popcorn
remember is a call back to Zoe's low
calorie video that clearly really love
popcorn popcorn popcor their plan
involves them confusing the dodc agents
by disguising themselves all all in the
same red hoodies and hats a trick that
we actually saw in the 1999 remake of
The Thomas Crown Affair and in my
favorite episode of Nathan for you
outside Barry asks if he can multiply
now and not to the Marvel mutant
multiple man not that mutant Berry so
they set up one of the skeletons to stab
a knife into a balloon that pops the
ingredients together to make the Foam
now notice they dressed up the skeleton
to look like Norman bates's mother from
psycho they put a wig on it and they
also put a face and hair on the balloon
it makes no sense how many steps they
added to this but I love it come on and
Camron hide in this office this is
actually Mr Wilson's guidance counselor
office now remember camon interrupted
Kamala and Bruno's kiss at the wedding
and now Bruno Returns the favor to be
the um uh kissmas Bruno distracts the
soldiers you know you like these moves
hey guys what's going
on OU this is actually what happens
whenever I try to dance government
soldiers just come in and hit me in the
face but notice how it looks like Bruno
is doing the same moves that he learned
for the wedding dance Nakia bikes into
the gymnasium where the volleyball state
champion banners also adhere to Accurate
MCU timeline logic 2024 would have been
the most recent season earlier that fall
they also won in 2022 2019 and 2012 2019
2022 would have meant that they won two
championships during the blitz I assume
all the other volleyball teams were just
very depressed in the bathroom there is
a poster for the hero volunteer Club no
powers no problem every bit counts I
mean I mean it kind of counts every kid
who didn't have powers in the school got
arrested KRON figures out his mother is
dead she tried to destroy
everything she was trying to save all
world yeah there's that nma music sting
again and as camaron steps out to attack
the dodc The Sting plays for him as
well and then every time he does
something really bad it kind of seems
like najma's disembodied soul is kind of
possessing camran in this episode Camron
uses his nor for hostile attacks while
Kamala uses her powers defensively she
forms a shield to protect both of them
but dver wipes it out with the big Sonic
Cannon just like the truck mounted one
in the 2008 Hulk film but then Cala says
it and begin yes the magic word for the
comics that we have been waiting for
because this is what Camala is supposed
to do she's supposed to Igan in this
case it is the no stretching out her
Limbs and we see a slightly scaled up
version of Cala and I love how this pays
off the references throughout the series
to Ant-Man her various Doodles the mural
and Karachi her comparing herself in
episode two to ant-man's Eternal youth
our girl finally imigs now the quick
editing suggests they might have had
limited VFX budget to show this on
screen for too long and really few shots
give us a sense of her actual scale but
there is one quick cut as Chron flips
over the truck at the crowd wide shot
shows her to be about 10 ft tall and
this hero shot of Cala with her Igan
fists is the angle of her Thor love and
thunder uses when they added her to that
movie's Marvel Studios title card Kamala
encases them both in a dome of their own
nor so they can have their heart to
heart now while the series retcons
Kamala as a mutant instead of an inhuman
I like to think that this Dome does at
least represent a teren cocoon for them
at least metaphoric Al both of them
emerging from it transformed kamala's
transformation to her final form is
really the final layer of her suit armor
her Jersey City Community forming a
human shield including the jcpd all of
whom have her back and as she flees off
into the night sky the overhead shot of
the crowd cheering noticed Bruno at the
center of it all just sadly pumping his
fist he's like yeah Caltech it is for me
then a Tik Tok Montage showing Paul from
episode 2 reenacting kamala's moves like
that Star Wars kid meme notice how his
name is master Paul 616 to the 616
Universe which this MCU is now
designated as of Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Manis we also see the
Sheik who later becomes a hot dog filter
and then the Euro king najaf and the
mosque bro and Mr Wilson AKA gww not the
bridge proving that he was the guy
defending NightLight on Tik Tok and
episode 3 then Auntie Ruby and then this
account she looks so familiar yes the
real gww is a cameo by G Willow Wilson
the actual Comics writer behind the 2014
series that this is all based on then it
ends with this little jerk he's a
freaking action superhero Mad Skills yes
ham Dizzle is the shoe Thief whom Camala
saved in episode 2 his caption of course
is ice cream pizza for life because he
loves it we get this moment where Cala
nervously takes in her own reflection
and Strikes her comics pose this
bookending kamala's awkward adjustments
to her cosplay in front of the mirror
back in episode 1 back then she was a
pretender now she is the real deal
Yousef tells his daughter and if you
saved one life well you saved the
world yes this is a verse from the Quran
whoever saves the life it is as though
he had saved the lives of all mankind in
this case saving camran literally saved
this realm from destruction and if you
remember back to the first Iron Man
Yensen and Tony Stark time proved that
by Saving Tony Stark he saved everything
in reality Yousef reveals that they
named her Kamala because Kamal means
perfect in Arabic while in Urdu it is
closer to wonder or Marvel making her
their little Miss Marvel so if you think
about it her mother gave Kamala the suit
that was made from gifts from wed and
kareim with a Sigil from her necklace
that had her own name in erdu her
grandmother provided the bangle Bruno
provided the mask and now her father
provides the name Ms Marvel and I just
love the shot of Yousef watching her
go
magic absolute magic we see her leaping
away reflected in the lenses of his
glasses and Camala sits on the lamp
light looking across the river at
Manhattan her red scarf in the breeze
recreated directly from the cover of Ms
Marvel number five and I always just
love how this image frames Cala as a
Jersey City hero not rumbling with the
bigger names in the city but opting to
protect her home neighborhood on this
side of the river one week later Bruto
shows up wearing a shirt reading either
gigawatt or jigawatt either way and not
do his past Marty McFly look and
explains why the bangal and the Norah
empowered Camala but not the others of
her family making the boldest
Declaration we have heard in the MCU in
quite some time Cala there's something
different in your
jeans
like like a
[Music]
mutation whatever it is it's just going
to be another label holy yes that
was Ron W's 9s X-Men animated theme
which we also heard when Charles Xavier
floated in in Multiverse of
Madness yes folks kamalak Con in the MCU
is a mutant this is the first 616
character defined as such in the MCU and
hearing the word mutation is such a huge
deal now making Kamala kind a mutant is
a redcon from the comics where Kamala is
an inhuman now just a bit of background
on the Inhumans the Inhumans were really
established in 1965 in the 80s Marvel
kind of back bured them as the X-Men
really became the dominant title of the
brand until 1998 when a really great
award-winning series by Paul Jenkins
revitalized the Inhumans and then in the
2000s when Marvel Studios began
producing films and TV Marvel CEO Ike
pearlmutter overseeing a different
division of Marvel like the merch and
the toys separate from Kevin feige perut
temporarily halted new X-Men comics from
being written to instead focus on titles
like Inhumans why to give the company
away way to produce mutant esque movies
and TV shows without having to go
through Fox because Fox owned the X-Men
so basically PE mutter was like stop
doing X-Men Comics we don't want to help
out a rival Studio which is a real
bummer because in previous decades new
Marvel heroes would get introduced and
just be casually established as mutants
but Kamala Khan got her powers by
breathing teren mist and entering a
cocoon and coming out with stretchy
Powers categorized as an inhuman so we
could look at this as Kevin feige just
restoring Kamala Khan to what she
probably would have been if not for
Pearl mutter's weird business decision
then again fans of the Inhumans and the
ways the Inhumans were explored in the
ABC series and Agents of Shield might
see this as inhuman eraser and I totally
hear them but as much as I really love
inhuman characters like blackbolt and
Quake I don't need Kamala KH to be an
inhuman as well and blackbolt being in
Multiverse of madness means that
Inhumans exist throughout the Multiverse
including this one most likely and
Camala being a mutant opens up other
doors for the MCU remember at Comicon in
2019 Kevin feige did promise that
mutants were coming but he did not say
X-Men necessarily just mutants and now
we learn this is what he meant mutants
of course include the X-Men but also the
mutant Brotherhood The Runaways Deadpool
neyar is technically Marvel's first
mutant and we're going to meet that guy
in Black Panther wak forever and do not
be surprised if they call him a mutant
in that movie and of course Wanda
maximoff and her sons are also often
considered mutants mutants all share the
mutant gene or the X Gene it occurs
randomly throughout the population and
can get triggered by puberty trauma or
energy exposure or some other kind of
stimulus in kamala's case it was the
bangal kamala's bloodline came from the
Nord Dimension but no one else in her
family had powers even with the bangal
only Kamala because of her unique mutant
Gene activated by the bangal that allows
her to draw power from her ancestral
Dimension yes it's a little confusing
yes it might have made more sense just
to May her an inhuman but oh well now I
get mutants and along with Kamala many
more individuals will soon be
established to have a mutant Gene as
well maybe some who have always been
here just outside of our view like n 616
Magneto could have still had an origin
in World War II we just haven't seen it
yet other mutants may arrive into 616
From Another Universe via an incursion
like how 838 had Patrick Stewart as
Professor X and Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
is confirmed to join the MCU with Secret
Wars on the horizon any number of
beloved X-Men actors could join the MCU
as well look folks we're going to be
discussing the mutants a lot more in
future videos this was a seismic Game
Changer and I am stoked Nakia says get
in losers we're getting shat both a nod
to The Avengers favorite post battle
snack and the line from Mean
Girls get in loser we're going shopping
the closing credits merge imagery from
Jersey City and karach showing how both
sides of kamala's worlds are now United
then on to the post credit scene where
kamala's Bengal glows a new color and
her body twists into ribbon and then she
wakes up as Captain Marvel Carol daners
Brie Larson making a cameo while at
first this reads like a nod to kamala's
initial transformation as she left the
terrien Cocoon into a doppelganger of
her hero Captain Marvel in the comics
really what happened here was Cala and
and Carol swapped places because she
doesn't look at her own body in the
mirror confused she just kind of looks
around her surroundings confused where
she is but notice how Carol's suit is
updated whereas before it was blue on
top and red in the midsection in legs
now it is red on top and blue everywhere
else down to blue boots it actually
looks more similar to her 9s look at the
end of the Captain Marvel film she also
does not wear the full red Gauntlet
length gloves her forearms are bare now
with shorter wrist length fingerless
gloves also notice kamala's
teleportation just looks different than
you'd expect her body twists into
ribbony putty we haven't seen this kind
of production design in the MCU there's
no glowing portal thank God it's a whole
new design meaning a completely new form
of technology and Magic is unfolding
before our eyes and in Marvel Comics
when characters like Nightcrawler
teleport they're actually traveling
through the medium of another dimension
in between those points for Nightcrawler
it's the brimstone Dimension here I
think it is teleportation through the
Negative Zone because I think the bangal
is alien cre Technology based on the cre
Nega bands from Captain Marvel comic in
those Comics the Nega bands were given
to Captain marll by the cre Supreme
intelligence and trapped him in the
negative Zone meanwhile on Earth former
Avenger Rick Jones uses these bands
clinks them together to trade places
with Captain Marvel just like these two
women are swapping places so I think
Carol was in possession of the other
bangal the long lost one assuming these
Bengals are crech and that the 10 rings
are crech the pulsing Beacon of the 10
Rings could have been summoning the cre
Empire to Earth to acquire the second
bangal meanwhile Carol found one of
these Bengals and In This Moment
spatially swapped places with Kamala and
the reason Carol says oh no no no no is
that maybe she was in the negative Zone
in that moment and now she knows she is
now cosmically handcuffed to some poor
girl who loves her but now she doomed
that girl to a frightening Dimension
setting all this up for the Marvels next
summer and since Kamala is now a mutant
who knows maybe it makes it likelier
that Rogue will appear in that movie and
drain Carol's Powers but I use the word
doomed and that was no accident my
friends because I think Doom is going to
play a very big part in all this the
Multiverse of Madness producers just
confirmed that they designed Reed
Richard's portal on the technology of
Victor Von Doom's time platform I think
the MCU may be bracing to introduce Doom
so there we have it folks mutants time
travel the Negative Zone teleportation
the 10 Rings alternate Dimensions the
dodc magic Scot LS podcast and then all
of it wrapped together in a hug of
wholesome family coming of age Vibes
with a killer soundtrack I loved this
show today it is such an honor to be
with M Marvel Kamala herself the first
to be identified of a certain beloved
category of Marvel superhero in the 616
MCU or is it 616 well we'll talk about
that we got Iman volani here with us
today thank you so much for chatting
with me Iman welcome thank you this I
I'm so glad I got experience them
welcome back to new rock stars intro
that's dream come true man amazing well
this is a dream come true for us too
we're we're obviously a huge uh fan of
you here on this channel this is
actually the first time we we' had an
Avenger with us in the blue dungeon well
are you an Avenger can we call you an
Avenger is that okay ooh I I consider
myself one that's no
one's granted me the the access to
calling myself that but we'll see
eventually maybe yeah how how does
someone get nighted and Avenger we saw
you know Tom Holland get like the the
nighted thing and you know people like
us are like okay so that is definitively
how one becomes an adventure then I know
there's some sort of initiation process
it's it's all in Kevin F M now yeah uh
and I I just also asked because like I I
don't know I don't go on cruises but
people are like going on cruises seeing
videos of you with Anthony Mackey and
they're asking me to break it down and
I'm like I don't know what this is I
don't know what it is we shot it like I
I got to London to film the Marvels last
year and it was like the first thing we
shot as soon as I got out of quarantine
and everyone was so confused what we
were filming they just like handed us
the script and then put me on some green
boxes and I was like jumping from one
thing to another and like talking to
Anthony Mackey's recording um it was
weird it was fun but weird yeah I think
that's a testament to uh to how well you
are handling this you know marvel actors
are not given enough credit for the the
guessing game that you all have when
you're cast on these things and the fact
that you just look so calm and collected
and confident in the way that you're
playing Camala and just look like you
are in on the loop and part of the plan
and it seems like there's no confusion
at all in the way you've been doing this
I I feel like I've prepped my whole life
for this I think you are part of that
reason now that I think about it just
like the theory breakdowns the trailer
breakdowns the poster breakdowns all the
breakdowns I feel like the YouTube nerds
are the the backbone of this fandom you
know let's let's actually talk about
your background a little bit because you
know obviously you're the first of many
things in the MCU again congratulations
on on how well you've been doing it's
just been a delight to watch you on the
show uh and I think part of the reason
we love you here at new rockstars is the
fact that you are a bit of an eggh head
like we are like you know I think you
might be the first true MCU fanatic to
actually get cast as a Marvel Superhero
you know a lot of actors claim that
they're fans but when you you know
follow up with them impress them they'll
be like well my kids love the
Spider-Mans and they told me at cool but
is it true you know that you carry
around a notebook filled with MCU
facts do you have it on hand I love it
this thing goes everywhere with me I
think this is um Kevin fy's biggest fear
this notebook don't let that out of your
sight no I'm like terrified of like
leaving it somewhere and then everyone's
just like finding my deepest darkest
Secrets no but um it's it's funny so the
first time I met Kevin was over zoom and
I was just hyperventilating and then go
to production and they're like okay
Kevin's coming on Wednesday and it's
Monday and he comes and I just like
stared at him until he left I couldn't
verbalize words or be a human at all and
so I had written this like four-page
letter in case I wasn't able to talk
again and the first page was like me
gushing over him the next three were
like 70s something questions I had about
him and the MCU like how much hours of
sleep he gets and like things about the
fandom in general and and he like called
me the next day and answer the first 40
and so the rest of the questions that he
hasn't heard are in here and every time
I get the opportunity it's like so why
did you do
this I mean you were never allowed to
get to the end of that list I want you
to just keep asking him questions
because I'm think you're giving him
ideas you're giving him great ideas I'm
sure for the future I I like to think so
I love it I have on standby my notebook
that I bring into movie screenings like
whenever I go I was gonna ask what is
your like process are you intervie now I
see literally every time new projects
are now so I'm like my God all the work
that these guys have to do you know are
you are you doing okay are you getting
sleep that is so sweet of you to ask me
that like I'm uh that's so kind of you
like com just happened and I'm like
these
guys no sleep for the God no rest for
the Weir I you know look this is a a
labor of love here in new rock stars and
I'm so honored to be able to do what we
do and to have this as a job and like I
think the only downside is you
know when I go watch movies it I do have
to bring this notebook and I am
scribbling the whole time and like I'm
not allowed to like take my eyes off the
screen so I use my thumb to just like
keep my place in a dark movie theater
and I'm like I'm close to the end of the
page I'm writing on my pants now so I
have to flip uh so it is work but like I
don't know it's I can't complain about
my job being to watch uh hilarious
awesome shows like Miz Marvel and and
everything else um I also wanted to ask
uh you if just to make sure it's okay
you know you've done a ton of interviews
like it's crazy you know for prepping
for this interview I'm like watching you
on Jimmy Fallon or on The Daily Show and
I'm like well I'm not Jimmy Fallon I'm
not Trevor Noah but I am a a YouTube
Nerd and I feel like I want to get your
permission is it okay if we just geek
out about the MCU for the rest of this
interview yes please this is I was
honestly most I did Jimmy fall I did all
of those but I was like most nervous for
this one because I have no idea what
you're gonna ask and I like have so much
respect for you and like this entire
channel it's a weird full circle moment
but yeah let's do it for this interview
we're now an honorary new rockstars
co-host so welcome welcome we we got
someone on the inside of the MCU so
welcome back to the
dungeon yeah I need hello tshirt if it
didn't smell so bad after a weekend of
Comic-Con coverage I would be wearing it
now um but um okay let's talk about Miz
Marvel and spoiler warning for anyone
who hasn't had the delightful
opportunity to watch Miz Marvel in that
those six episodes they are so much fun
please go watch them uh and enjoy them
because this show has everything like I
had no idea how many corners of the MCU
this show would touch on and and what it
means to be a nerd and uh we got to
start with the big one so in the finale
episode you were established as the
first mutant that's identified in the
MCU and I assume you saw the comic on
announcements this past weekend no
mutants so far announced on the schedule
but we assume they're coming I assume
you can't talk too much really at all
about where we might see mutants next
but I just want to ask you as a fan of
all this where do you want to see
mutants show up next o God I don't even
know we didn't even know that scene was
even going to make the cut we shot it
not knowing if it was gonna happen like
I got sent that script before re-shoot
for our show started and I was like
freaking out emailing everyone texting
everyone in all caps I was like is this
happening please tell me I'm like IM mut
um and we we shot it we were like still
crossing our fingers hoping it was going
to make the cut and it did and and it
was literally all up to Kevin it was the
literally how this happened was son our
producer was in one of the writer room
meetings and she's like what if we like
we can't figure this out like what if we
just made our mutant or something Kim's
like okay and that's it so I don't know
what their plans are I would love to see
just like more you know mutants pop up
and I you know Neymar's coming just just
a lot of people established as mutants
and then eventually we get some sort of
X-Men team up together that'd be awesome
absolutely yeah I I I think it seems to
be the plan you know watching Multiverse
of Madness we were like okay well they
have Patrick Stewart coming in and maybe
that's the way they're going to do it
but then two minutes later we're like I
guess not uh but I like this approach of
just establishing characters like you
who are just who have that genetic
predisposition I think that's like a
more organic way to go and I'm glad that
you get to be part of it I know what an
honor I mean like especially working
with sa and knowing like you know they
wanted to make her an a mutant in the
first place and it was a weird time in
comic so it didn't happen but uh it's
it's so exciting and and everyone I
couldn't get any takes where I wasn't
giggling except the one that we saw on
Disney plus literally every single time
Matt said the word I I had to break it
was just like too good to be true
yeah Iman I loved the way you delivered
it too like you did this thing that
sometimes if you watch like outtakes
from Saturday Night Live some actors uh
will to keep from breaking will
go that's literally that's the closest
we can get to me not
breaking was so
wonderful I'm so excited to see them
like cut it all together like all my
terrible outakes of me just like
laughing I I had it was terrible and
Matt did such a good job and just saying
the word and I couldn't say the word in
real life for the longest time until
like recently I kept calling it the m
word it just give me chills yeah well
and the MW can mean anything in the MCU
right like we have Mesto we have House
of M you know the m word has so many I
am so excited the day that Mesto
actually comes into the MCU greater than
your birthday oh me too yeah I think
I'll have to change my birthday to that
date you know when he
arrives um okay so it's interesting to
hear how that came about I assume
something like that had happened because
it's interesting when you watch the
episode this scene almost feels like a
post-edit scene it comes after we have
this moment where br going to be we like
it just felt too again we needed to you
know like kind of keep people watching
before sure the actual post credit scene
so yeah it totally was meant to be one
and it felt like this nice Coda with
Bruno and N I love that Nakia gets the
Mean Girls reference with the schwarma
worked in it was like my favorite joke
that episode but do you have any uh
insight into what might have been in
Bruno's note because we never saw what
was on the note that he put in your
locker that's a great question we did
have so that that last lampost shot that
you saw we did have a version where it's
Camala reading the note that that Bruno
left for her and they had written this
this like fake note for me but they
didn't show me what it was until I read
it so I would get all emotional or
whatever um but I I think that's
something we're going to explore in in
season two if if that happens I hope it
happens I think all these characters
have a lot of story left to tell um but
yeah I maybe it's Bruno's you know just
pouring his soul out and then confessing
his love for Cala who knows yeah that'd
be great uh so talking about that
post-credit scene it you know it's been
confirmed that uh Kamala and Carol
Danvers by by The Producers uh that they
did swap places we also learned that
that the director of the Marvels ni a
Costa actually shot that that scene
which which we speculated it felt like
it had a slightly different vibe to it
did you know when he shot that scene
where Camala might be transported to
what did they tell you was happening in
that moment I'm like and again you can
plead the fifth you don't have to say
too much because I know it ties in with
the next movie so we we did shoot that
in the Marvels not during Miss Marvel so
I do know the story because I was in the
movie but um yeah they they did switch
places where did she go we'll find out
in a year okay I can't wait to find out
you know we're looking for clues or just
a sense of context I like how Carol says
oh no no no no and runs away and the way
I read that is she's like worried where
where this fan of her might now be um
like can you at least give us a sense of
what kamala's initial emotional reaction
when she arrives somewhere new or even
you could just like make a face into
like what how she might be feeling where
she is now oh God a lot of fear and
excitement at the same time of where she
up that's that's what I'll say all right
I will make 12 Theory videos about that
answer I wanted to ask you uh actually
let's do a little segment here called
that I'm just gonna call deunk DeVos
this is where uh you know I have there's
some questions about how exactly
kamala's Powers come from her mutation
because obviously introducing her as a
mutant seems like an answer to a
question but she has the nor light she
has the bangle she has the X Gene all
three seem to be NE necessary and my
explanation on this and I I kind of want
you to debunk this uh but like I'm
thinking that the the mutant Gene might
be the lock mechanism her family history
with a nor Dimension might be on the
other side of that lock door the source
of her power and the bangle is the key
that unlocks the lock to open the door
is that the case do you think specific
to Kamala Khan or do you think this
could be uh a way to describe all
mutants in the MCU going forward I I
feel like it's specific to cala I think
you're on the right track with it
because we never really fleshed it out
just because we didn't know if it was
the scene was actually going to happen
but I made many Theory boards prior to
filming because I was so
confused um the way I justify it to
myself is like yes the Bengal unlocks
her X Gene I think her actual mutant
power is the ability to facilitate the
no so she is part Jen and she's part
human but she can do what comron can't
like I don't think kron's a a mutant
because he can't harness the Nord the
way that Kamala does he can't like
control it the way she does and I I
think that's kind of her power yeah
that's kind of what I'm going with that
that her ability to kind of make shapes
out of it is is like the mutant P like
like armor from the X-Men it's it's a
very similar Vibe and I think that's
kind of what inspired you know the the
the way we animated Camala yeah I like
that I like that there has to be some
kind of like biological component a like
a muscle memory that you're reconnecting
with in order to be fully mutant I like
that approach um but she can use her
powers rather bangal because a lot of
people are like oh the bangal is what
like lets her use her powers I I do
think it's just something that unlocked
it and hopefully we'll get to see her
without the bangal using her powers yeah
I like that too I like the bangal is
almost like a spark plug it just kind of
it's what gets it all started but it's
not a battery that's continuing
continuing to power
um actually I wanted to ask about that
moment one of my favorite moments from
the season is when w explains the nor
Dimension we see this awesome
holographic map display of the
dimensions architecture there's like a
tree and you know me I'm like going
frame by frame through that I want to
ask you as someone who shot that scene
what did you see like what what was in
the script what
nothing
nothing dude it was like four LED lights
in a
circle and they were like this things
happening and or like where do we look
they're just like in the middle but not
like down but like kind of up but not
too high just like in the general middle
and there's like a map
and because a lot of this the times we
don't always have previsit to like see
what it looks like for for scenes where
it's like not fight scenes and so it was
just using your imagination be like oh
yeah this is what the nor Dimension
looks like okay cool yeah it's it's
weird it's it's mostly just LED lights
even kamala's Powers the way we film it
is like I'm standing on plexiglass and
we shine purple light underneath it I
love it and and anytime I I hear answers
like this I'm it just blows my mind that
you as actors are able to make this look
so believable like you were reacting to
it in the moment it just feels like I
don't know like I took some acting
classes in college but I don't think I
could ever believably go on a green
screen set and be like this is actually
something I'm holding or looking at I
honestly it wasn't that hard if you ask
the right questions especially with the
powers because this is such a new power
set and something we haven't seen in the
MCU yet and so it's stressful because
everything we established now is going
to be Canon for the rest of the MCU and
so we had to be really careful about
like you know my physicality and
whatever you know how we Manifest this
how difficult is it for Cala to you know
make these shapes how what does it look
like what does it feel like and so just
sitting down with their bfx people
asking all these questions and then they
come up with these pre visualizations of
what the scenes are going to look like
and so it gives you a bit of an idea
because it's like a cartoon version of
of what it's going to look like for real
and yeah but otherwise it's just really
awkward and it's dead silent on stage
and you're just like this pretending
like you're saving people's lives I mean
I think that's such a smart question to
ask of how it feels like how hard is it
to do this because yeah there are
moments where it seems to burden or or
or strain Camala to uh be making these
shapes
which is just interesting to watch for
sure I want to ask you about time travel
uh major twist in the seriesa goes back
in time to the 40s during the partition
to cast a trail of stars and that is the
historical trail of stars that saved her
own grandmother um and you know the the
time travel egghe heads here call this
like a causal Loop or predestination but
did you have questions for how the logic
of this time travel fits in with what we
saw in aventures endgame or in Loki yep
first thing I asked I'm like doesn't
this break all the rules and they're
like
H we'll figure that out
um I I think the Marvels is gon to
explain it a little more to be
fair God I want to tell you things but
this is gonna be on
YouTube it's it's fine I understand it's
totally good I don't want to get you in
any trouble I I I do think you know oh
God no I can't I can't in a year please
call me
back I absolutely we're going to talk
more about this on the other side of it
but I think one thing that we can at
least infer from these phase five and
six announcements is that you know Kang
is really the future of the MCU and I
think one thing if you one
interpretation of Loki could suggest
that all of this was prescripted at
least by he remains or some other
variant of Kang and I just wanted to ask
like do you think it's possible and this
is just nerd speculation you know if if
you can't speculate on it without
bringing in what you already know do you
think Kang or he remains might have
planned specifically for Kamala to go
back in time yeah okay so the
inscription on the bengle used to be
what is destined for you will come for
you we did change it after that but I
like to use that as a way of you know
justifying how Cala goes back in time
and and why that was meant to happen
because there was so many questions and
we really wanted to bring partian in the
story and and just I know it's it's
cramming a lot in in episodes four and
five but you know we didn't know if we
were going to have season two and we had
to put all our Cs on the table and just
like show everything about this culture
and and and you know the history of it
and so that line what is destined for
you will come for you that used to be on
the bangal is kind of a good sense of
you know this was meant to happen
predestination even if it kind of hurts
the endgame time travel rules but so
does old Steve Rogers so exactly exactly
you know you know how it works so yeah
Kevin FY is the Kang of this universe
that's how I like to yeah I think so too
I think at some point we need an Easter
egg where Kevin feige can just be
revealed as the one above all or one of
the Kang variants or something like that
he knows he knows actually you bring up
like I loved learning about the the
history of the partition I think it was
referenced in some high school history
class I took but it's not something
that's that's talked enough about I'm so
glad that this show could go into that
and and humanize it in in this beautiful
way and I I honestly I have to confess
what you seek is seeking you was my
favorite line of this of this miniseries
and like one and I have to also say I
initially interpreted it as oh it's like
a warning like the person you're hunting
down is going to stab you in the backs
to watch your back and then the next
episode my heart melted when it was
contextualized as what you just
described this sense of destiny that
your deepest hopes and desires are just
as eager to find their way to you you
know this this line from roomie the Sufi
poet and Mystic and I honestly I'm
writing my wedding vows right now and I
almost put that line in but I thought it
might be a little hokey but I want to
ask you was there any line or scene in
the series that was especially
meaningful For You
O um the first time in episode three
it's not even like that momentous of a
scene I mean I guess it is the first
time Kamala uses her big in hand at the
wedding after Bruno breaks his arm so we
we had like two takes to film that and
there there was a version where we said
in bigin but it didn't feel right in
that moment but it was it was the first
time that we see her in bigin properly
and I just I wanted to get it right and
we had two takes to do it and sa our
producer she's on set every day and I
just I only care about her approval and
so like we do the shot and it was really
like annoying technically because all
the action scenes are just so
exaggerated to look better on camera and
you know it's not how you naturally
would punch just because you know we
need to go this way and lose some face
in the frame for the big fist and so it
was really hard and and I thought I did
a really shitty job and then I was like
crying and and son after just like came
up to me and was really proud and and it
looked really good and it just felt
really good and watching it felt really
good and so that like little moment just
all the little comic Booky moments I I
just appreciated a lot even even seeing
partition it was one of the most
stressful things to film just cuz it
felt so real and and we were in Thailand
in the middle of the night it was like
like 40 degrees it was terrible we had
costume changes midday because we would
sweat through our costumes and so that
entire scene was also like really
emotional for a lot of people but yeah I
honestly the entire show just had
moments where either from the comics or
from my culture I I definitely re like
embrace my culture a lot more now after
filming the show is crazy yeah I think
it's been like an enlightening
experience for everyone watching this
show just to learn both about uh like
the culture of Karachi and then as well
as like Jersey city and what it means to
just spend an afternoon shopping with
your mom like I thought it was so
beautiful all right I got to ask you I
read the red at AMA where you said that
after you said that the MCU wouldn't be
616 on the red carpet that I guess Kevin
feige saw you the next day and stared
you down and just went like and walked
away I think about that every day it's I
okay I get it I get it I get he makes
decisions that's fine he's done a great
J job I'm just trying to you know it's
convenience you now you have to specify
comics6 versus MCU 616 and I'm just
trying to save everyone's breath you
know like it's a
lot yeah Kevin just does like 9999 so I
get and I don't blame them there's too
many nines to say you don't you lose
track of your nines three nines in so I
get it 616 I think is a nice clear slate
but it it does require further
explanation you know you have to like
remind people well then the movies are
an adaptation of the comics as opposed
to a universe alongside them um does all
I used to think about it which is why I
disagreed with the
616 but yeah why why can't do anything
about
it after going through this process
you're now in the midst of it does it
give you a greater appreciation for how
the execs build this universe or do you
think it's still like something can be
MCU Canon if enough fans believe it to
be true are you still clinging to that h
that's a good one okay well I there are
a lot of things that are planned
so far ahead and and you don't even
realize until things just click and
you're like oh this is a moment where we
can bring back this from this movie and
it's just incredible how these guys like
come up with this stuff and and you know
try to tile the pieces together and then
there's a lot of seeds that we plant
that we don't have plans for and then
like five years down the line they'll be
like oh remember that let's do that it's
like I honestly like Iron Man Too and
just like having the little neyar and
then um W kind of references on the map
I feel like that was never planned but I
don't know but now it's you know coming
into play and it's awesome seeing how
many Easter eggs that weren't even
planted and you guys made just out of
thin air it's it's amazing especially
now being a part of this and then
watching your breakdowns and be like oh
we didn't even plan that but did that
works you can take credit for it you can
absolutely take credit and that's what's
just so cool about what growing up at
the MCU is seeing little like Atlantis
references in the middle of the ocean on
a map and then now they can pay it off
like 10 years later it's just really
exciting and then I guess the last thing
I want to ask you we know that Peter
Parker's on YouTube I have a theory that
he's just posting under an anonymous
account like the videos that he self-
reccords of himself is there a chance
that Peter Parker and Camala Khan might
have come across each other's content
kamala's got her YouTube channel I'm
sure I'm sure I would love to see them
like just talk about and be like wait I
subscribed to yours too um yeah that
that' be fun I think they they had such
fun Vibes in the comics as well and
those te ups were one of my favorites
hopefully we'll see it soon well we will
leave it there but Iman thank you so
much it was such a delight to be able to
meet you and to chat with you and I I
can't wait to chat with you more after
we see you next in the MCU yes I have so
much to spill cuz like I want to tell
you you're wrong about things but I
can't tell you what you're wrong about
it hurts until I'm proven wrong I'm
right thank you for this this was F I
think that's the the trick you
know well thank you again Iman I just
want to say thank you and keep up the
great work thank you you too get some
sleep okay back to present day Voss with
a 2023 update Marvel Studios has
actually updated the Statue of Liberty
since this series dropped to make it now
bronze colored to better fit with a
continuity of Spider-Man no way home and
in the Marvel's film The Statue is
bronze colored after reading MCU the
random Marvel Studios the amazing 2023
book written by Joanna Robinson Dave
Gonzalez and Gavin Edwards it's
fascinating to learn that Kamala Khan
was always intended to be a mutant in
the comics and was only made an inhuman
in the comics to appease the Marvel CEO
Ike permut who told the company to hold
back on mutants and the Fantastic B so
characters wouldn't be as popular for
the fox movies who had the film rights
at the time and they were a rival Studio
at the time but now Disney has
reacquired all those rights so by Marvel
Studios retconning Kamala Khan as a
mutant baptized with Ron W's X-men theme
from the the fox series that's just a
very important indicator of Marvel's
plans for Cala going forward and be sure
to watch my early 2023 video diving deep
into the actual history of 616 versus
199999 especially in the context of
Spider-Man across the spiderverse
because both sides of that debate are
misinformed and I explain why support
new rockstars with this Flur and shirt
at nerd riot. shop subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network follow me at eaos thanks for
watching I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
la